I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Welcome. Welcome back to the return. We're returning with the return. Do you see what we did there? See that? I like that. We're geniuses. No one can top us. Guys, this is season three episode 13. This was written by Jean Stupnitzkeli Eisenberg and Michael Shore and directed by Greg Daniels. Jenna, let's have a summary. All right, here we go. Oscar returns to work. He's returning from his
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。欢迎。欢迎回到《归来》。我们带着《归来》回归了。你们发现我们刚才玩的小把戏了吗？看到了吗？我喜欢这样。我们真是天才。没人能超越我们。伙计们，这是第三季第13集。本集由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基、李·艾森伯格和迈克尔·舒尔编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。珍娜，给我们来个剧情总结吧。好的，我们开始吧。奥斯卡重返工作岗位。他结束了
vacation to an elaborate Mexican theme party that he didn't ask for and doesn't really want. Sounds about right. With Dwight gone, Andy fights hard to win Michael's favor, but crosses the line. Jim and Pam team up to prank Andy and ultimately bait him into an angry meltdown. When Michael learns from Angela that Dwight's supposed disloyalty was actually just a misunderstanding, he goes to Staples to win Dwight back. And Dwight returns. It's a double return. And there it is. It's a double return. Jenna, I feel like if we were to title this episode from Angela Martin's point of view, I would like to title it snow and sadness. There are so many snowflakes and tears falling in this episode. There's some serious moping and snow. Yeah, it's so true. Well, Angela,
假期，迎来了他并未要求也并不是真正想要的、精心准备的墨西哥主题派对。听起来差不多就是这样。随着德怀特离开，安迪极力争取迈克尔的青睐，但却做过了头。吉姆和帕姆联手捉弄安迪，最终激怒了他，导致他情绪崩溃。当迈克尔从安吉拉那里得知德怀特所谓的背叛其实只是一场误解时，他前往史泰博公司去把德怀特争取回来。接着德怀特回来了。这是双重回归。就是这样。这是一次双重回归。珍娜，我觉得如果我们要从安吉拉·马丁的角度来给这一集起个标题的话，我想把它叫做“雪与悲伤”。这一集里有太多的雪花和落泪了。这里面有一些相当认真的生闷气和下雪。是的，千真万确。好吧，安吉拉，
that leads me very well to fast fact number one, which I called it's snowing in Scranton. It was such a fun backdrop to the whole episode. I know. We also got a lot of fan questions about it. Alisa Schroeder, Mariana Gonzalez, Holly Gannett and Paige Carter all said in this episode, it is constantly snowing. How did you do it? Was there a video there? Did they use a green screen? Well, I mean, I think we all know who I asked about this. Please tell me you hit up Kentopedia. Oh, lady, you know, I did. And you know, he delivered because he's amazing Kent Zabornak. Thank you so much for always being there for us. So first of all, on one of the first pages in the script, there is this note and it says, through the window, we see that it is snowing. Michael doesn't
这非常自然地引出了我们的第一条快讯，我把它叫做“斯克兰顿下雪了”。这为整集节目提供了一个非常有趣的背景。我知道。我们也因此收到了很多粉丝的提问。丽莎·施罗德、玛丽安娜·甘萨莱斯、霍利·加内特和佩奇·卡特都说这一集里一直在下雪。你们是怎么做到的？那里有视频吗？他们用了绿幕吗？好吧，我的意思是，我想我们都知道我向谁打听了这件事。请告诉我你联系了肯托百科全书。哦，天哪，你懂的，我联系了。而且你知道吗，他真的给出了答案，因为他太棒了，肯·扎博纳克。非常感谢你一直以来对我们的支持。首先，剧本的第一页上有这样一条备注，上面写着：通过窗户，我们看到外面在下雪。迈克尔并没有
notice it should be snowing throughout the entire episode. So this was noted in the script. The writers came up with this idea. It's going to pay off when Michael's car fills with snow. But we also just used to like to represent the season that the show would be in when it aired. So even though we shot this in October, it was going to air in like January or February, it would be winter in Scranton. I love it. I love that throughout the episode, you see people like having talking heads and it's just coming down. I just love that little detail. Well, here is what we did to make it snow in those talking heads, Angela. We used the same company that we used in the Christmas episode, the first Christmas episode. Remember them? Snow business. And they use this very old
注意到整集都应该在下雪。所以剧本里写了这一点。编剧们想出了这个主意。当迈克尔的车里积满雪时，这个伏笔就会产生效果。但我们也只是喜欢展现节目播出时所处的季节。所以尽管我们是在十月份拍摄的，但它会在一月或二月左右播出，那时斯克兰顿应该正值冬日。我太喜欢了。我喜欢整集中，你会看到人们在进行单人访谈时外面雪一直在下。我就是喜欢这个小细节。好吧，安吉拉，这就是我们为了在那些单人访谈中制造下雪效果所做的事情。我们使用了我们在圣诞节那一集、第一集圣诞节时用过的同一家公司。还记得他们吗？“雪上加霜”（Snow Business）公司。他们使用了一种非常古老的
fashion technique. He said they've been using it for decades and they still use it today. They take like a large roller and they put it behind the window. And it has like, what's the thing that you put your pasta in to drain it? Are like a sifter when you do powdered sugar? Yes. So it's a giant rolling sifter that they fill with snow and then they just crank it. There's like a dude back there cranking fake snow like through a giant sifter. Yeah, there can be a dude or a lady or it can be on a little motor. It just spins endlessly and snow falls out of it until you fill it again. And he even sent me a picture of it. So I will put it up on our office ladies pod Instagram. Oh, I want to see that picture. Yeah.
传统技术。他说他们已经使用这项技术几十年了，而且今天还在使用。他们拿一个大滚筒放在窗户后面。里面有什么东西，就是那种你用来滤面的东西？或者像做糖粉时用的筛子？对。所以这是一个巨大的滚动筛子，里面装满了雪，然后他们就转动它。后面有个小伙子在转动摇柄，通过一个巨大的筛子制造出假雪。是的，可以是个小伙子，也可以是个姑娘，或者也可以装在小电机上。它会无休止地转动，雪就会从里面落下来，直到你再次把里面填满。他甚至还给我发了一张照片。所以我会把它发到我们的办公室辣妈播客Instagram上。哦，我想看那张照片。嗯。
And then the same company snow business would come and put all the snow and ice on the ground. And they had this big blower machine where they would like blow it all over the bushes. I remember the blower machine, but I don't think I ever went back behind where the windows were where we did talking heads. And I never got to see the sifter. Well, there's a little gap, you know, there's like the wall and then there's a gap and then there's that scranton backdrop that we would also change seasonally. So we had a snowy backdrop. And then we had a little sifter fellow or sifter person. Yeah, exactly. Well, I love that fast fact. Well, fast fact number two, Angela, remember last week we talked about how this
然后那家叫“雪上加霜”的公司会过来，把所有的雪和冰铺在地上。他们有一个大型吹风机，可以把雪吹到所有的灌木丛上。我记得那个吹风机，但我认为我从来没有去过窗户后面我们拍单人访谈的地方。我也从来没见过那个筛子。嗯，有一个小缝隙，你知道的，有一堵墙，然后有一个缝隙，然后就是那个我们也会按季节更换的斯克兰顿背景。所以我们有了一个下雪的背景。然后我们有一个小筛子小伙子或者筛子姑娘。对，完全正确。好吧，我很喜欢那个快讯。好了，第二条快讯，安吉拉，还记得上周我们谈到这一集
episode and traveling salesmen were shot as one big episode. And our director of this episode and our showrunner Greg Daniel sent in a bunch of audio clips where he mentioned some of the inspiration for these two episodes. Well, he did it again. And he sent in an audio clip about some of the things that they were juggling for this portion of the storyline. So Sam, will you play that clip? These were like extremely complex storylines. There was a lot of good stuff between Pam and Angela, between Dwight and Angela, between Michael and Dwight. And these stories brought in lots of cards that we had on the boards. One of the things that we would do in pre-production is we would generate all these funny ideas for different storylines or fragments
和《旅行推销员》是一起当作一大集来拍摄的吗？本集的导演兼节目统筹格雷格·丹尼尔斯发来了一组音频剪辑，其中他提到了这两集的部分灵感来源。好吧，他又这么做了。他发来了一段音频，谈到了他们在处理这部分故事情节时所兼顾的一些事情。萨姆，你能播放一下那个音频吗？这些是非常复杂的故事情节。帕姆和安吉拉之间、德怀特和安吉拉之间、迈克尔和德怀特之间有很多精彩的内容。这些故事引入了我们在白板上贴的很多卡片。我们在前期制作中会做的一件事，就是为不同的故事情节、片段
or B stories. And they would become note cards that would be push pinned into the courtboards. So there's a lot of cards. I recognize cards in the stories that had been on the boards, like I think the Mexican themed party, for instance, was a card for Oscar. And certainly the Pam and Angela relationship or Andy being more sinister and Michael having to wise up and realize who his most loyal servant was. These are all fragmentary ideas that we combined into a great episode, I think. A lot of moving parts. Yeah, I love picturing the writer's room and these cards and them coming back around. And Greg, I love when you send in audio clips. Thank you. I agree. Fast fact number three, ready to do Ed Helms. You heard her,
或B故事产生所有这些有趣的点子。它们会变成便签卡，用大头针钉在故事板上。所以有很多卡片。我认出了故事中那些曾贴在板上的卡片，比如墨西哥主题派对，对奥斯卡来说就是一张卡片。当然还有帕姆和安吉拉的关系，或者安迪变得更有心计，以及迈克尔不得不变得精明起来，意识到谁才是他最忠诚的仆人。这些都是我拼凑成的一个我认为很棒的剧集的零星点子。有很多移动的部件。是的，我喜欢想象编剧室和这些卡片，以及它们如何重新组合。格雷格，我喜欢你发音频剪辑。谢谢你。我赞同。第三条快讯，准备好迎接埃德·海姆斯了吗？大家伙，
everybody. We talked to Ed Helms about this episode. This is such a big episode for Andy. He is driving most of the storyline. He is the instigator. We absolutely had to talk to Ed, so we did and it was great. It was so fun. Sam, play the interview. Ed Helms. Hello. How are you? Hi, office ladies. Ed, it's so good to see you. You got an office guy right here in the mix. We do. We got an office fella. We got one of the best office fellas. Well, thanks so much for being here, Ed. People just love Andy Bernard and we're so excited to talk to you about this episode. Yeah, I rewatched a little bit just so I had it in my head for this chat because I never watch it unless I happen to see it on in the background
你们都听到她说的了。我们和埃德·海姆斯聊了这一集。这对安迪来说是非常重磅的一集。他在推动大部分故事情节的发展。他是挑事者。我们绝对必须和埃德聊聊，于是我们照做了，而且非常棒。太有趣了。萨姆，播放采访。埃德·海姆斯。你好。你好吗？嗨，办公室辣妈。埃德，很高兴见到你。咱们这里就有个办公室的伙计。没错。我们有个办公室伙计。我们有个最棒的办公室伙计。埃德，非常感谢你能来。人们就是喜欢安迪·伯纳德，我们很高兴能和你聊聊这一集。是的，我重新看了一小部分，这样在这次聊天时我脑子里能有个印象，因为我平时从不看它，除非碰巧看到它在某个地方的背景里
somewhere. But I love it when I catch it. Yeah. Yeah. Have you ever had that experience though where you're like flying on an airplane and you see it on all the screens that people are watching it on all their personal devices and on the airplane and then you're just sort of sitting there? Please don't notice me. Please don't notice me. Yeah, I'm always like, do I go to the bathroom? Do I not go to the bathroom? I was trying to time it out to go to the bathroom one time and like there was someone in there, so I was standing outside and I was on the little screen above my head and I just started to see the faces, look at me, look up, look at me, look up and I was like, oh god. Oh, that's amazing. Angela, I would expect you to just sit down on someone's arm rest and
播放。不过我挺喜欢偶然看到它的。对。对。你有过那种经历吗，就是你坐飞机时，看到所有人都在个人的设备上以及飞机屏幕上看着它，然后你就在那里坐着？请不要认出我。请不要认出我。对，我总是想，我是去洗手间呢，还是不去洗手间？有一次我试图算准时间去洗手间，结果里面有人，所以我站在外面，而我头顶的小屏幕上正放着我，我开始看到那些面孔看着我，抬头，看着我，抬头，然后我就想，哦天哪。哦，太棒了。安吉拉，我本以为你会直接坐在别人的扶手上，
be like, hey, you having fun? You enjoying the episode? We got any questions? I'm happy to talk about. I've exchanged more email addresses with flight attendants and made good friends on planes. Literally, I sat next to a woman one time and we're still friends to this day. We're total strangers flying to Canada. Ed, you watched part of the return? Yeah. Yeah, I rewatched the return. I watched just a couple of episodes from that first chunk of season three because that was my first time on the show and it feels so long ago. It's just not fresh in my mind so many of those experiences and so rewatching it, I was hoping I could trigger a lot of memories of the experience and the emotional memories and so forth and it was a joy. It was really, really fun.
然后说：“嘿，你玩得开心吗？你喜欢这一集吗？我们有什么问题吗？我很乐意聊聊。”我和空乘人员交换过更多电子邮件地址，还在飞机上交到了好朋友。真的，有一次我坐在一个女人旁边，直到今天我们还是好朋友。我们是飞往加拿大的完全陌生的路人。埃德，你看了《归来》的一部分吗？对。对，我重新看了《归来》。我只看了第三季前几集中的几集，因为那是我第一次上节目，感觉是很久以前的事了。其中很多经历在我脑海里已经不新鲜了，所以重看的时候，我希望能触发我对那段经历的很多记忆和情感记忆等等，这真是一段欢乐的时光。真的非常非常有趣。
When I watch it, I get a sense memory of my desk. I know that they've torn it down now and they do a lot of game shows where our set used to be and I was even invited to go on one of them and I turned it down because I didn't think that I could emotionally handle walking into the sound stage and not seeing Pam's desk. At Chandler Valley Center Studios, they do game shows now? Yes. I did to tell the truth and when I got the address, I said, yes, I would do it and I don't know where things tape so I was like, sure, I'll do it and then I got the address and it was Chandler Valley Studios and I was like, what? I showed up at our studio and I started sobbing because it was just so weird to pull up to that building. Oh my gosh.
当我观看它时，我会对我的办公桌产生一种感官记忆。我知道他们现在已经把它拆了，而且在我们的布景以前所在的地方做了很多游戏节目，我甚至还被邀请去参加其中一个，但我拒绝了，因为我觉得自己无法在情感上承受走进摄影棚却看不到帕姆办公桌的打击。在钱德勒山谷中心制片厂，他们现在做游戏节目吗？是的。我参加过《说实话》（To Tell the Truth），当我拿到地址时，我说，是的，我会去，而且我不知道录制地点在哪里，所以我就想，当然，我会去的，然后我拿到了地址，那是钱德勒山谷制片厂，我就想，什么？我出现在我们的制片厂，然后我开始号啕大哭，因为开车驶向那栋大楼实在是太奇怪了。哦天哪。
There were a lot of major chapters in our lives that people went through, marriages, divorces, children, all these major life events that were happening and sometimes I'll see an episode and I'll be like, oh yeah, that's when so-and-so was going through this or that's when so-and-so child was born and that stuff's really beautiful to remember. Even the parts that might have been painful chapters, they're still merely meaningful chapters in our lives and histories and it's just so wild to have this show that's kind of a bookmark, right? You can just go to any point. I mean, for us, having made the show, I can recall things that I was experiencing when I see a scene or if I catch a chunk of an episode, I can remember where I was in my life
我们的人生中经历过许多重大的篇章，婚姻、离婚、孩子，所有这些重大的人生事件都在发生，有时我看到一集就会想：“哦，对了，那是某某正在经历这个的时候，”或者“那是某某的孩子出生的时候，”记住这些真的非常美好。即使是那些可能是痛苦篇章的部分，它们在我们的生活和历史中依然具有极有意义的篇章，拥有这样一档节目作为某种书签，真是太疯狂了，对吧？你随时可以翻到任何一个点。我的意思是，对我们来说，制作了这部节目，当我看到一个场景或碰巧看到一集的一部分时，我能回忆起我当时正在经历的事情，或者我能更好地回想起我在生活中的位置。
a little bit more. That is so true. It's really wild. Like I said, even the ups and downs of it, it's all beautiful, right? Just to have those triggers available to remember those things, just feels very beautiful overall. Yeah. Yeah. This, as you were saying, is such a big storyline for you, traveling salesmen leading into the return, and were you super excited to get this script to see what all you got to do and play with Steve and like you got to in this episode? Yeah, of course. I mean, it was still early enough for me. I mean, every table read is a joy, right? It's just so much discovery for the cast. The writers have been kind of in the trenches for a couple of weeks or months at that point with every episode. But for us, it's like this fresh,
那真是千真万确。真的太疯狂了。就像我说的，无论是高潮还是低谷，一切都是美好的，对吧？只要有这些触媒来回忆那些事情，整体感觉就非常美好。对。对。正如你所说，对你来说，从《旅行推销员》到《归来》，这是一个非常重磅的故事情节，当你拿到这个剧集，看到你所有要做的事情以及与史蒂夫一起表演的内容时，你是不是超级兴奋？对，当然。我的意思是，对当时的我还说还算早。我的意思是，每次剧本围读都是一种欢乐，对吧？对演员来说有那么多的发现。在那时，编剧们已经在每一集的战壕里熬了好几周或好几个月了。但对我们来说，这就像是一件新鲜的、
exciting thing. And I do remember feeling, as I got more sort of meat on the bone in some of those later episodes, it just felt, it really felt like an affirmation that Andy was a valuable part of this cast overall and of the show. And so, yeah, there was always a kind of giddy anticipation with those table reads, like, oh, what am I going to get to do? What did the writers come up with? And then, of course, how is Steve going to make me laugh this week? Right. And this episode opens with your phone ringing, and there's like a four-part harmony of you singing your ringtone. Is that you? 100% me. All four parts? All of it? Yeah. Yep. And I did it. And just like Andy says in the show, I did it on my computer at home.
令人兴奋的事情。而且我确实记得，随着我在后面那些剧集中获得更多戏份，那种感觉真的就像是一种肯定，证明安迪是这个演员阵容整体以及这部剧的一个有价值的部分。所以，是的，在那些剧本围读时总是有一种兴奋的期待感，比如：“哦，我能做些什么呢？编剧们想出了什么点子？然后，当然，史蒂夫这周要怎么把我逗笑？”对。这一集一开场就是你的手机在响，然后你用四声部合唱唱出了你的铃声。那是你吗？百分之百是我。所有四个声部？全都是？对。没错。而且我做到了。就像安迪在剧里说的那样，我是在自己家里的电脑上做的。
You Ed did it on Ed's computer at home. They didn't like bring you into a studio or something. No, I think they... That tracks, actually. That does track for our show. Like, hey, can you do this whole thing at home on your flip phone or whatever we had at the time? Well, I can't remember. I think maybe, I don't think they wanted it to be very good, but I was like too into it to make it anything less. And I thought Andy would make it as good as possible, right? So I think I spent a long time on that in GarageBand, kind of figuring out how to do multiple tracks. But yeah, I recorded it, and I sort of figured out four parts to it, which was really pretty simple. I mean, it's a very elementary kind of harmony arrangement.
你埃德是在埃德家里的电脑上做的。他们没有把你带到录音室或者什么地方吗？没有，我想他们……这倒挺符合实际的。这确实很符合我们节目的风格。比如，嘿，你可以用你的翻盖手机或者我们当时用的什么设备在家里完成这一切吗？好吧，我不记得了。我想也许，我不认为他们希望它做得很好，但我当时太投入了，绝不允许它变得平庸。而且我认为安迪会尽其所能把它做到最好，对吧？所以我当时在GarageBand（库乐队）上花了好长时间，琢磨怎么制作多轨录音。不过是的，我把它录下来了，而且我琢磨出了四个声部，其实挺简单的。我的意思是，这是一种非常基础的合唱编排。
But yeah, super fun. And then I played it for Greg, and he was like, great, we'll use it. I feel like, Ed, because I know you were in an acapella group, right, in college. Well, yeah, that's a little bit of an overblown history. I was in an acapella group, but only for a semester in college. It wasn't like a huge part of my identity. Although it was for a semester, but then I just kind of realized it wasn't for me. But you have an ear for music, like there is no way they could have given that assignment to Jen and I. I know, you're like, it's a pretty easy harmony. And I'm like, is it? It is. Yeah, you're very talented. Well, since we're talking about famous Andy Bernard things,
不过，是的，超级有趣。然后我把它放给格雷格听，他说：“太棒了，我们就用这个。”埃德，我觉得，因为我知道你曾在一个无伴奏合唱团里，对吧，在大学里？哦，是的，那段历史有点被夸大了。我确实在一个无伴奏合唱团里，但在大学里只待了一个学期。那并不是我身份中很重要的一部分。虽然确实待了一个学期，但后来我只是觉得那不适合我。但你对音乐很有天赋，他们绝对不可能把那个任务交给我和珍娜。我知道，你会觉得：“这只是个挺简单的合唱。”而我会想：“是吗？”确实是。是的，你非常有才华。好吧，既然我们在谈论安迪·伯纳德的标志性事物，
I need to ask you about... I have the script and I have not once ever seen it written in the script for Andy Bernard. You had to have invented this. I improvised a ton in my early episodes because again, I was eager to prove myself and I also was trying to find Andy Bernard as a character. And that particular thing, which I think this was the first episode where it appeared for Andy, right? Yes, yes. And so it just was this thing that these guys I went to middle school with would say they would just inject into... It was kind of like a, there you go, gotcha. If they got off like a good zinger at your expense, they'd tag it with it. And I don't know if they weren't exactly
我得问你关于……我有剧本，但我从来没在安迪·伯纳德的剧本里看到过这个词。这肯定是你发明的。我在前几集的表演中即兴发挥了很多，因为还是那句话，我很急于证明自己，我也在试图找到安迪·伯纳德这个角色的感觉。而那个特定的东西，我想这也是安迪的这个特点第一次出现的一集，对吧？是的，是的。所以这只是我和初中时一起厮混的那些男生会说的话，他们会把这句话随口加入……这有点像那种“就是这样，抓到你了”的感觉。如果他们在你身上抖了个好机灵，他们就会用这句话来做结语。我不知道他们算不算得上是恶霸，但我只记得初中时有那么一小撮男生有点喜欢抖机灵。我不知道它在此之前是从哪里来的，我把它学了过来，一直觉得这是一种既有趣又讨厌的表达方式。它没有任何含义，只是随你心意插在任何地方都行。
bullies, but I just remember this little clump of guys that were sort of like wisecrackers in my middle school. And I don't know where it came from before that, picked it up and always thought it was kind of a funny, obnoxious expression. It has no meaning and it just kind of fits in wherever you want. It's so perfect, Ed. I have such a memory of being in Scranton with you, Ed. Do you remember? I remember like, we were there for the office convention and there were so many people there and you and I were in a car and like there were people all around the car and we went into that train shop and we had to exit out the back.
太完美了，埃德。我在斯克兰顿和你在一起的记忆太深刻了。你还记得吗？我记得，我们在那里参加办公室粉丝见面会有好多人，你和我坐在一辆车里，车周围全都是人，我们走进那家火车模型店，不得不从后门出去。我的意思是，没错。我们正开车穿过斯克兰顿市中心，然后我就想：“哦，天哪，那是莱恩尔（Lionel）火车，模型火车店。我们必须进去。”我让车停下来，然后你和我一起下去了，人们开始挤压玻璃，就像是，我们就像是，太疯狂了。他们把车开到了后面。我们不得不从后门出去，而那个模型火车店的老板是个老绅士。他根本不知道我们是谁，也不知道发生了什么。他好像在说：“我想你们可以使用后门什么的。”然后我们上车了，你就说：“安吉拉，这是我们离披头士最近的一次了。
I mean, that's right. We were driving through downtown Scranton and I was like, oh my god, it's a Lionel train, model train store. We have to go in there. And I made the car stop and I made and you got out with me and we went and people started to press up against the glass and it was like, Mike, we were like, it was crazy. They had, they pulled the car around the back. We had to like exit out the back and the man that owned the model train store, he was like an elderly gentleman. He had no idea who we were or what was happening. He was like, I guess you can use the back door or whatever. And then we got in the car and you're like, Ang, this is the closest we'll ever be to being a
这是我们的时刻。”但我提起这个是因为，面对着人群，埃德转过身对他们说，然后他们彻底疯狂了。哦天哪。到现在如果有人在机场尾随我，比如：“嘿，埃德·海姆斯，安迪，安迪，最近怎么样？”我只要随口扔下一句，然后他们就会……他们就会走开。然后他们就晕倒了。好吧，埃德，我想问你关于你拳打墙壁的那场戏，因为我和我的孩子们一起重看了这一集。我的孩子们现在都长大了，埃德，他们喜欢《办公室》，他们喜欢安迪，我们蜷缩在床上看了这一集，他们咯咯笑得厉害，他们想知道关于这件事的一切。比如，你有什么关于打墙壁的故事吗？你真的打了吗？那是什么感觉？
beetle. This is our moment. But why I bring it up is that to a crowd of people, Ed just turned to them and said, and they lost their minds. Oh my gosh. That's still like if someone is kind of trailing me in an airport like, hey, Ed Elms, Andy, Andy, what's up? I'll just make toss a rid it to do and then they're like, they'll leave me alone. And then they faint. Well, Ed, I wanted to ask you about the scene where you punch the wall because I rewatched this with my kids. My kids are older now, Ed, and they love the office and they love Andy and we curled up in bed and we watched this episode and they were giggling so hard and they wanted to know anything about it. Like, do you have any story about punching the wall? Did you really do it? What was it like?
我知道珍娜在前排的接待处有最佳视野。会计部从远处看着。好吧，这很有趣，因为从技术上讲，那是一个特技，对吧？从制作的角度来看，诸如此类的特技特效需要有人监督。所以我还记得这是我第一次做任何符合特技标准的事情。因此有一个小小的会议，讨论他们将如何划破干墙的背面，以便我的手更容易穿过去，然后他们会安装一个护垫，就像把一个垫子固定在内墙上，这样当我的手穿过去时，我就不会撞到木头、铝材或任何东西。此外，他们还准备了多块可以插上去的木板，这样我们就可以拍好几个镜头。
I know Jenna had a front row seat at reception. Accounting watched it from afar. Well, it's funny because that was technically a stunt, right? From a production standpoint, the sort of stunt affects people have to oversee something like that. And so I remember it was my first time doing anything that qualified as a stunt. So there was a whole little meeting about how they were going to score the back of the sheet rock so that my hand went through easier and then they were going to put up, they like fixed a pad onto the inner wall so that when my hand went through, I wouldn't hit wood or aluminum or anything. And also, they had multiple planks that they could stick up just so we could do multiple takes.
但它仍然……我的意思是，你们俩都知道，每当你们作为一个角色掌控整个开放式办公区时，都是令人畏惧的，对吧？这是一种我一直对此感到焦虑但又带有积极意义的事情，就像是一种，你知道的，我总是对那种事情充满干劲。这也是为什么我对卡瑞尔始终充满敬畏，因为他的许多场景都是和整个演员阵容一起完成的，他在和整个演员阵容对戏。这太难了。我的意思是，这真的需要极大的专注力和注意力，因为每个人的台词都是针对你的台词做出反应，而不是相反，所以你必须推动场景的发展，而不是成为那种只是对别人的台词做出反应的人，
But it's still, I mean, you guys know anytime you as a character are holding court for the whole bullpen, it's daunting, right? It's kind of something that I think was, I always felt anxious about in a good way, like in a kind of, you know, I was always amped up for those kinds of things. It's also what makes me just stay in awe of Carell because so many of his scenes were with the entire cast where he's like running a scene with the entire cast. And that's so hard. I mean, that is just, it is a really, it takes a tremendous amount of focus and concentration because everyone's lines are responding off of yours as opposed to, and so you have to drive the scene as opposed to being someone who's just responding to somebody else who's,
而这正是我们所有人与史蒂夫一起做的事情。所以对我来说，那是其中一个场景，而且是非常早期的场景，我认为既令人兴奋又有点令人生畏。我真的不想把那一拳砸搞砸了。我不想弄错，或者有很多预备动作来练习挥拳，如果你这么叫的话。然后我想我们大概只拍了两次就过了。我的指关节擦破了。我确实记得，你知道的，我有……里面有护垫，但我还是觉得，击穿干墙擦破了我的指关节。所以，是的，那相当激烈。我记得你为那一幕流了点血。我记得那个。但我也记得作为一个坐在开放式办公区看着这一切的人，我怎么都不能笑场，因为我知道
which is what we all got to do with Steve. So that was one of those scenes for me and a very early one and something that I think was very exciting but also kind of daunting. I really didn't want to screw up the punch. I didn't want to get it wrong or there were a lot of kind of wind-ups to practice swings, if you will. And then I think we only did up two takes or so. And I skinned up my knuckles. I do remember, you know, I got, I still, there was a pad in there, but I still, I think breaking through the sheetrock skinned up my knuckles. So yeah, that was pretty intense. I remember you shed some blood for that one. I remember that. But I also remember feeling as a person who was in the bullpen watching how I could not break because I knew
你当时承受的压力。而且我也知道我们没有那么多墙。他们有多余的，但也不是有14面。所以在你拳打墙壁时，我们不能笑出声。我们必须控制住自己。所以我记得当时的感觉是：“哦天哪，好吧，咬住嘴唇内侧。无论你必须做什么，千万别搞砸了。”哦天哪，有太多那种时刻，极力克制自己不去看不该发生的事，因为太搞笑了。因为我……我只能记得，我觉得那就是我们大部分的一天。如果我在开放式办公区拍那种场景并且不想笑，我就会盯着右边三英尺处的墙壁。这就是我的秘诀。我总是只是
the pressure you were under. And I also knew we, we didn't have that many of the walls. They had extra, but it's not like they had 14. So we couldn't crack up when you punched the wall. We, we had to hold ourselves together. So I remember it being like, oh boy, all right, bite the inside of your lip. Whatever you have to do, do not mess this up. Oh my gosh, there's so many of those moments of trying to not look at what's happening because it's too funny. And because I, I can just remember like, I feel like that was most of our day. If I were in the bullpen for a scene like that and, and didn't want to laugh, I would just be looking at the wall three feet to the right. Just cause that was my trick. I always just
看着别的地方，因为每个人……每个人都太TMD搞笑了。我以前看着史蒂夫的脖子。我跟你说，这太奇怪了。对，我看了他耳朵好多次。但我喜欢你看着他的耳朵。我看着他的脖子。对。我通常会看着他的额头。这就是……史蒂夫的这些部位。对。我可以把他的耳朵讲得头头是道。对。史蒂夫现在大概会想：“哦，天哪。”你说的对。迈克尔·斯科特的很多特质都体现在那些眼神里。如果你锁定了它们，你就完了。就像迈克尔·斯科特那海啸般的喜剧效果会直接向你席卷而来。我几乎从来没有办法在和他对戏时保持镇定。哪怕只是最蠢的一点小插曲，他也能……好吧，你们俩在
looked somewhere else cause everyone, everyone's just so damn funny. I used to look at Steve's neck. I tell you that's so weird. Yeah, I looked at his ear a lot. But I love that you were looking at his ear. I was looking at his neck. Yeah. I would usually look at like his forehead. This is, these are the parts of Steve. Yeah. I can tell you all about his ear. Yeah. Steve right now is like, oh, good Lord. You're right. There's something like so much of his, of Michael Scott was in those eyes. And if you locked in on them, you're done. Just like all of the, the tsunami of comedy that is Michael Scott would just like wash over you. And I could almost never keep it together with him. Even just the dumbest little moments he just. Well, you guys had
这一集里有那么多精彩的时刻。比如我喜欢你在他办公室里告诉他类似“我要去喝一杯，我要去嗨了”那样的话，然后你跟着他去了洗手间。对。那……那是什么感觉？我要去厨房。我跟着你。我陪你走过去。对。哦，天哪。对。所以，我的意思是，编剧们只是，你知道的，有那么一些编剧，尤其是迈克·舒尔，我们在那个时期真正建立了深厚的感情，因为出于某种原因，迈克·舒尔以这种非常奇怪的方式真正懂安迪·伯纳德。我的意思是，也许迈克·舒尔身上也有那么一点安迪·伯纳德的影子。但我的意思是，他们为这个角色想出的那些点子，当我读到这些剧本时，或者在剧本围读时，我都会想：“没错，这就是安迪会做的事。
so many great moments in this episode. Like I love when you're in his office, like telling him about like, I'm going to get my beer on, get my lost on and you follow him to the bathroom. Yeah. What, what was that like? I'm on my way to the kitchen. I'll follow you. I'll walk you there. Yeah. Oh, gosh. Yeah. So, I mean, the writers just, you know, there was something, a few of the writers and Mike Schur in particular, we really bonded at that time because for some reason, Mike Schur just got Andy Bernard in this really weird way. I mean, there may, maybe there's some bit of Andy Bernard in Michael Schur as well. But I mean, the stuff they came up with for him, I would read these scripts or, you know, be at the table read and I'd be like, yes, this is exactly
这绝对是我脑海里的安迪、我所理解的那个角色的行为方式。”所以，我一下子就懂了。我觉得这些场景简直是天作之合，就像穿上一件舒适惬意的毛衣。我的意思是，你们俩都知道，编剧们对演员们的关注是如此之密切，以至于他们已经……而且在第二季末或第三季初或更早的时候，会发生一件绝妙的事情，那就是编剧开始根据演员的优势来写作，或者针对某些性格特征、举止习惯或者那些开始涌现的极其具体的特质来进行创作。而且，迈克·舒尔和我经常坐在一起，想出一些关于安迪是谁、他的背景和家庭生活的段子，然后
what Andy would do. This is exactly how the Andy in my head, the way that I think about him would behave. And so I, I just got it. I felt like these scenes were like such a perfect fit, like putting on a nice, comfy sweater. I mean, you guys know, the writers paid such close attention to the actors that so that they've, and it's that great thing that happens around late in season two or season three of a show or even earlier than that where the writers start to write towards the strengths of the actors or towards certain personality traits or mannerisms or just these incredibly specific things that start to bubble up. And, and Mike Schur and I would just sit around and like come up with bits about who Andy was and his background and his family life and, and just
笑得前仰后合。我们对这个角色有着如此共同的理解，以至于像那样陪迈克尔去洗手间的事情——虽然太疯狂了——但对我来说，安迪这样做完全说得通，而且演起来纯粹是一种享受。好吧，我可以告诉你，埃德，当演员们看到你出现在场景中时，当你终于来到剧组——你知道的，因为我们看不到你们，你们在斯坦福，我们没机会和你们互动。而当我们终于看到你出现在场景中时，你演砸了每一个场景，你太搞笑了。我记得我极力克制自己不笑场。那曾是我的目标：当史蒂夫做什么的时候不要笑，当史蒂夫做什么的时候不要笑。然后突然之间，我又不得不加上另一层要求：现在当埃德做什么的时候也不要笑。哦，天哪。
die laughing. And we just had, we just had such a common understanding of, of the character that things like that walking Michael to the bathroom, which is so insane, but it made perfect sense to me for Andy and was just a joy to do. Well, I can tell you Ed that the cast, when we got to see you be in scenes, when you finally came, you know, because we didn't see you guys, you guys were over at Stanford and we didn't get to interact with you. And when we finally got to see you in scenes, you just crushed every scene you were in and you were so funny. And I remember trying so hard not to laugh. It used to be my goal, don't laugh when Steve does something, don't laugh when Steve does something. And then all of a sudden I had to add this other layer of like, now don't laugh when Ed
哦，太甜了。安吉拉，我记得和你一起大笑，笑得那么厉害，关于迈克尔试图播放自动点唱机却无法开始放歌，于是安迪开始唱起《舞国英雄》（A Night at the Roxbury）的歌。是的。那在……那是《合并》那一集吗？是的，我想是的。我想是吧。是的。而我们俩会那样做，你和我只会做那个做好几个小时，把彼此逗得哈哈大笑。爱是什么？我们的化妆车是挨着的。所以你就是那个人，你知道的，我只要走出我的门，拐个弯，你就在那里。而且我记得走过你的化妆车，因为你会把门开着，你在弹斑鸠琴什么的。我走过你的门，然后学着：“pee, pow, pow, pee, pow, pow, pow。”哦天哪。好吧，
does something. Oh my God. Oh, that's so sweet. I remember laughing with you, Angela, so hard about the Michael's trying to play a jukebox, but he can't start the tune. So Andy starts doing the night at the Roxbury song. Yes. That is in, is that in the merger? Yeah, I think so. I think. Yeah. And we would do, you and I would just do that for hours and just crack each other up. What is love? Our trailers were side by side. So you were the one, you know, I just walked out my door and went around the corner and there you were. And I know I have this memory of walking past your trailer because you would have the door open, you'd be playing your band or something. And I would walk past your door and go pee, pow, pow, pee, pow, pow, pow. Oh my gosh. Well,
我喜欢加入安迪这个角色，因为你是德怀特的绝佳陪衬。吉姆总是捉弄德怀特或对德怀特恶作剧。你和德怀特之间有那种权力的争夺，我觉得太搞笑了。在重看时，我就是喜欢你和雷恩针锋相对的每一个时刻。这里面肯定有大量的即兴发挥，因为我觉得现在有了剧本，当我回过头去查看时，我现在可以看出不同的人的即兴发挥有多少百分比进入了正片。我必须说，你和雷恩·威尔逊的即兴发挥保留率是最高的。对，这很酷。好吧，直到扎克·伍兹加入剧组。然后扎克·伍兹直接把即兴发挥这一块给炸翻了。他是天才，而且他太聪明了。
I loved the addition of Andy because you were this great foil to Dwight. Like Jim would always tease Dwight or prank Dwight. You had this like power struggle with Dwight that was so funny to me. And in rewatching it, I just love every time you and Rain would face off. And there was, there must have been so much improv in that because I feel like now having the scripts, when I go back and look, I can see now percentage wise how much more of different people's improv's make it in the show. And I have to say that you and Rain Wilson have the highest amount of improv that makes the cut. Yeah. That's cool. Well, until Zach Woods joins the cast. And then Zach Woods just demolished the improv. He is a genius and he's so smart.
聪明绝顶，而且超级搞笑。不过是的，珍娜，很有趣。你说得对。我认为吉姆和德怀特的动态非常搞笑，因为吉姆是一个讲道理的人，而德怀特是一个有点疯癫、不讲道理的人。看到吉姆总是处于一种优越的角色中，把德怀特搞得团团转，既有趣又让人看着过瘾。安迪同样也是个疯子。所以他真得达到了德怀特的水平。我认为，这让他们的冲突超级有趣。对雷恩和我来说，这绝对超级有趣。我只能……是的，和那个家伙一起笑得前俯后仰。你们俩会为最蠢的事情争风吃醋。我的意思是，我知道这一集里没有，但有一个被删减的片段，你们俩为了谁是个更好的婴儿而针锋相对。
So, so smart and funny. But yeah, Jenna, it's funny. You're right. I think the Jim Dwight dynamic was hilarious because Jim was a reasonable person and Dwight is a sort of whacked out unreasonable person. And the seeing Jim always in a sort of superior role just messing with Dwight was fun and gratifying to see. Andy was also whacked out. And so he really was at Dwight's level. And that, I think, made their conflict super fun. It's certainly super fun for Rain and me. I just can, yeah, so many hard laughs with that guy. And you guys would compete over the stupidest things. I mean, I know it's not in this episode, but there's a deleted scene where you two are going head to head about who was the better baby.
你们在厨房里，然后你说：“嗯，我曾经是个漂亮的婴儿。我当过模特。所以，我曾经是个模范婴儿。我当过模特。”然后他说：“嗯，我太大了，我妈都走不了路，”然后你就说“太恶心了”。但这就好像是一场为最愚蠢的事情展开的疯狂竞争。是的，但你们在争论谁是个更好的婴儿，然而你们对“更好的婴儿”意味着什么的标准甚至都不一样。你们不是在争论谁最漂亮或者谁体形最大。这就像是一场复杂的、企图压倒对方的较量，我太喜欢了。哦，真是些有缺陷的角色。美妙的缺陷。而且我认为，安迪的那种小气对我来说有点像是一种宣泄，因为，你知道的，它……
You're in the kitchen and you're like, well, I was a beautiful baby. I was a model. So, I was a model baby. I modeled. And then he's like, well, I was so big. My mom couldn't walk and you're like gross. But it's like this crazy competition over the stupidest thing. Yeah, but you're competing over who was the better baby, but your standards for what better baby means aren't even the same. You're not arguing over who was most beautiful or who was largest. It's like this complicated one-upmanship and I love it. Oh, so such flawed characters. Deliciously flawed. And I think, you know, the pettiness of Andy was a bit cathartic for me because, you know, it just,
这是一种方式，我一直在说，我们在经历生活时都会有小气的反应、冲动和想法。但在安迪身上，我能够把所有这些全都淋漓尽致地表演出来。无论什么小气的冲动或本能冒出来。我只是能够通过安迪把它们宣泄出来。我太喜欢了，我太喜欢了，埃德，因为我必须说，当我想到你时，我认为你是最不小气的人之一。我的意思是，我甚至……我甚至连你抱怨的记忆都没有。我一直觉得你是这方面的榜样，因为那很有趣。你得让安迪把所有情绪都宣泄出来。好吧，是的，如果我没有扮演安迪，如果我没有那个情绪宣泄阀，我可能早就变成一个极其不稳定的人了。
it was a way, I was saying, we all have petty reactions and impulses and thoughts about going through life. But in Andy, I was able to just fully act out all of them. Like whatever petty impulses or instincts bubbled up. It just, I was able to kind of funnel through Andy. I love that. I love that, Ed, because I have to say, when I think of you, I would consider you one of the least petty people. I mean, I can't even, I don't even have a memory of you griping. I always found you to be such a role model in that way too, because that's fun. You got to let it all hang out with Andy then. Well, yeah, maybe I would have been a much more unstable person if I didn't get to play Andy, if I didn't have that release valve.
他平衡了你。是的。但我真的无法过分强调，你知道的，我……我对你们所有人在我们刚开始在斯坦福时给予的那种欢迎之情只有感激。不仅是你们，还有所有的编剧。然后当我们到达斯克兰顿的时候，那……非常可怕且令人畏惧。但我们从来没有，我只是……我们从来不觉得，好像有什么威胁。我们从来不觉得有什么必须克服的个人障碍来向你们证明自己。我们只觉得你们很高兴有我们加入。这是创造力得以滋养的最不可思议的、最不可思议的环境。我们，埃德，真的很想让你和克里德一起弹奏斑鸠琴和
He balanced you out. Yeah. But I really can't overstate, you know, the, just my gratitude to all of you guys for when, when we started in Stamford, just that feeling of welcome. And it was you guys, but also all the writers. And then when we arrived at Scranton, that was, it was very scary and daunting. But we never, I just, we never felt like, like there was any threat. We never felt like there was anything we had to, anything personal, we had to overcome to prove ourselves to you guys. It just felt like you guys were happy to have us. And that's the most incredible, the most incredible environment to be creative in. We, we really, Ed, someday want you and Creed to just play the banjo and
曼陀林，就像你们在片场做的那样。我不知道这怎么能塞进办公室辣妈播客里，但总有一天我们想让你来这里听听这个。随时，随时。这太有趣了。而且，是的，能和你们一起进入这种心境真的很有趣。所以谢谢你们。好吧，在我们离开之前，我想听听你和迈克·舒尔正在做的这部新剧。哦，是的。Peacock上的《拉瑟福德瀑布》（Rutherford Falls）。对。自从《办公室》之后，显然迈克去制作了这些极其精彩的节目。但是，我们，我们一直保持着密切的友谊。所以我们想出了这个角色，内森·拉瑟福德，他生活在纽约州北部的拉瑟福德瀑布小镇。他是拉瑟福德瀑布当地博物馆的馆长。
mandolin like you did on set. I don't know where this fits in an office ladies podcast, but someday we want you here and to hear that. Any time, any time. This has been so fun. And yeah, it's just really fun to get into this headspace with you guys. So thanks for that. Well, before we go, I want to hear a little bit about the new show that you're doing with Mike Schur. Oh yeah. A peacock called Rutherford Falls. Yeah. Ever since the office, obviously, Mike has gone on to do these just incredible shows. And, but we, we've stayed close friends. And so we just came up with this character, Nathan Rutherford, who is, lives in the small town of Rutherford Falls in upstate New York. And he is the curator of the local museum about Rutherford
他是镇创始人劳伦斯·拉瑟福德的后代。所以他极其热衷于拉瑟福德瀑布及其所有的历史。他还有一个最好的朋友雷根，她是美国原住民，在纽约州北部小镇旁边的印第安保留地长大。所以他们两个人，而且她还在她的保留地上经营着一个文化中心。但这，让人觉得有必要去探讨一下人们为什么会相信他们所相信的东西，以及为什么接受不同版本的个人叙事会如此困难，即使当你面对铺天盖地的证据证明你可能对你的历史、你的
Falls. And he's a descendant of the town founder, Lawrence Rutherford. So he's incredibly enthusiastic about Rutherford Falls and all of its history. And he also has his best friend, Regan, who is Native American and grew up on the reservation next to the town in upstate New York. And so the two of them, and she also runs a cultural center there on her reservation. But it just, it felt important to kind of address some of, some of the reasons why people believe what, what they believe and why, why it can be so hard to accept a different version of, of your, your own kind of personal narrative, even when you're confronted with like overwhelming evidence that maybe you're wrong about what you thought about your history or your,
小镇或任何事情有误解时也是如此。所以这才是这部剧的核心所在——这种友谊受到了挑战。而且它也超级、超级搞笑。听起来很沉重，我，我所描述的。它确实有一些沉重的主题，但它超级、超级、超级搞笑。我们在非常早期就把西娅拉·泰勒·奥内拉斯（Sierra Teller Ornelas）拉进来作为我们的节目统筹。我曾和她合作过《分居风暴》（Splitting Up Together）。嘿，原来如此。对。对。所以她，她就是我们的节目统筹，她简直不可思议。然后她组建了这支不可思议的编剧团队。我们一直在努力创作。不过，我们本该在封锁开始时就开拍的。现在我们只是在想办法弄清楚。
your town or whatever. And so that's really the crux of, of the show is these, this friendship kind of being challenged. And it also is super, super funny. It sounds very heavy, what I'm, what I'm describing. And it does have some heavy themes, but it's super, super, super funny. We roped in also very early on as our showrunner, Sierra Teller Ornelas. I worked with her on splitting up together. Hey, there you go. Yeah. Yeah. So she's, she's our, she's our showrunner and she's just incredible. And then she just put together this incredible writing staff. And we've been cranking on it. Well, but we were supposed to start shooting right when the lockdown started. And now we're just kind of trying to figure it out.
好吧，我等不及你们开始拍摄了，我们也可以开始观看了，因为听起来太棒了。在你们离开之前，还有什么想分享的吗，关于这部剧的任何回忆？如果有任何其他想说的，我们不想让你走，但也完全没有压力。这只是，这是我非常珍视的一段经历，作为其中的一部分。而且，那些经受住时间考验的友谊。我的意思是，我简直不敢相信我们所有人还在一个短信群里。这太让我震惊了。而且，我，我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢奥斯卡发的一小段话，然后克里德插话，每个人都在说，有时它们很有趣，有时它们，它们只是信息或新闻之类的内容。但它，我不知道，它说明了，
Well, I can't wait till you guys can start filming and we can start watching that because it sounds so great. Before you go, is there anything else you want to share, any memories from the show? We don't want to leave you, if there you have anything else to say, but also no pressure. It just, it's something I cherish so much having been a part of that. And, and the, the friendships that have endured. I mean, I can't believe we're all still on a text chain. That blows my mind. And I, I just, I love that so much. And I love the, just a little blurb from Oscar and then then Creed will chime in and everybody just, and sometimes they're funny and sometimes they're, they're just like information or news or whatever. But it's, it just, I don't know, it speaks to,
好的，我已经迫不及待想看你们开始拍摄，然后我们可以开始收看了，听起来太棒了。在你们离开之前，还有没有什么想分享的，关于节目的回忆吗？如果我们不想让你走，如果你还有什么话要说，但也没有压力。只是，这是我非常珍视的一段经历，能够参与其中。而且，那些经受住时间考验的友谊。我是说，我真不敢相信我们大家现在还在用短信群聊。这让我大开眼界。而且，我，我太喜欢这样了。我喜欢，奥斯卡发的一小段话，然后克里德就会插话，每个人都，有时候他们很搞笑，有时候他们，他们就像是信息或新闻之类的。但这，这只是，我不知道，这说明了，
I think that is what made, that's why the show has endured the way it has is because the, the camaraderie was real. Yeah. You know, the friendships and the, the kind of mutual love and support and respect was, was real on that set. And even though the characters were in, in like ridiculous conflict all the time, there was always, I think people could pick up on an underlying sense that, that, that Dunder Mifflin kind of had a foundation of love. Yeah. Oh. Does that make sense? Yes. Yeah. I love that. Well, Ed, thank you so, so very much for coming on and talking to us and sharing your stories. It's just been wonderful. And we'll bug you down the line because I have
我认为正是这一点造就了，这也是这部剧之所以能历久弥新的原因，因为那种，那种同甘共苦的情感是真实的。对啊。你知道的，片场里的友谊，那种相互的爱、支持和尊重都是真实的。尽管角色们在剧情中总是陷入荒谬的冲突，但我觉得人们总能捕捉到一种潜在的感觉，那就是邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）其实建立在爱的基石之上。对啊。哦。这讲得通吗？讲得通。对啊。我很喜欢这样。好了，艾德，非常非常感谢你能来跟我们聊天，分享你的故事。真是太棒了。我们以后还会不断骚扰你的，因为我有一个
a good dinner party story with you. You can't tell that story. I'm not telling that one. I'm not telling, wait, that's, I'm not even talking about that one. I know what you're talking about in the car. I'm not, I'm just talking about, I have a dinner party moment, but we'll get there. Okay. I can't wait to come back, guys. You're the best. Love you, Ed. Anytime. All right. Thanks, Ed. All right. Well, we are back. Jenna, let's get into this episode. Yeah. So guys, Dwight has left Dunder Mifflin and he's on the job market. So this episode opens with Dwight going on some job interviews. We see him interviewed by two different people,
关于你的不错的晚宴派对故事。你可不能讲那个故事。我才不讲那个呢。我不讲，等等，那个是，我甚至都没在说那个。我知道你在车里说的是哪个。我不是，我只是在说，我有一个晚宴派对的小插曲，不过我们等会儿再聊。好吧。我等不及要再来了，伙计们。你们是最棒的。爱你们，艾德。随时欢迎。好的，谢谢艾德。好啦，我们回来啦。珍娜，我们来聊聊这一集吧。好吧，伙计们，德怀特已经离开了邓德·米夫林，他在找工作。所以这一集的开场就是德怀特去参加几场求职面试。我们看到他接受了两个不同人的面试，
a man and a woman. And our fun cameo catch tidbit is that the man who interviews Dwight at the beginning of this episode is Kevin Riley. Kevin Riley, who was the president of NBC. You guys have heard us talk about him. He is the reason the office stayed on the air. He fought so hard for us. So this was really fun and special to have him sort of pop in and make it into an episode. Yeah. I asked Greg about this and he said he got the idea because Greg's father had worked as a radio executive and he was really funny and smart like Kevin, he said. And when he left ABC, they gave him a present that he could appear as a magician in one of their soap operas. Oh my God. So he thought this would be a really fun way, especially with the office being documentary
一个男人和一个女人。我们有趣的客串小彩蛋是，在这一集开头面试德怀特的那个男人是凯文·赖利（Kevin Riley）。凯文·赖利，他是NBC的总裁。大家听我们提起过他。他是《办公室》（The Office）得以继续播出的原因。他为我们争取了很久。所以能让他这样突然客串出现在一集里，真的非常有趣而且特别。对啊。我问过格雷格关于这件事，他说他是从这里得到的灵感：格雷格的父亲曾担任过广播公司高管，而且就像凯文一样既幽默又聪明，他这么说的。当他离开ABC时，他们送给他一个礼物，让他可以在他们的一部肥皂剧里客串扮演魔术师。天哪。所以他觉得这会是一个非常有趣的方式，特别是《办公室》采用的是纪录片
style to cast a real person, a real executive instead of an actor. And also this would kind of commemorate Kevin Riley's contribution to our show staying on the air. Oh, well then Dwight goes on to his second interview and it's a woman, right? And clearly, you know, we're picking up in the middle of the interview. She must have said to him to describe himself with three words. Dwight says he's hardworking, alpha male, jackhammer, merciless, insatiable. And as he's saying this, if you look around the office, it is the most feminine pink office you will ever see. Everything in it is pink. Every container on her desk, the paint on the wall is pink. The flower behind her is a whole bunch of pink flowers and Dwight is throwing out alpha male and it's like
风格，让一个真人，一个真正的电视台高管而不是演员来客串。而且这也算是为了纪念凯文·赖利为我们这部剧能够继续播出所做出的贡献。哦，然后德怀特去参加了他的第二场面试，面试官是个女人，对吧？很显然，你知道的，我们是从面试进行到一半时切入的。她一定让他用三个词来形容自己。德怀特说他是努力工作的、有男子气概的、打桩机般的、冷酷无情的、贪婪的。当他说出这话时，如果你环顾一下这间办公室，它绝对是你见过最具有女性气息的粉色办公室。里面的每一样东西都是粉色的。她桌上的每一个收容器，墙上的油漆都是粉色的。她背后的花是一大束粉红色的花，而德怀特却在抛出“大男子气概”这种词，而且还带着
merciless. And you can just sort of see her being like, hmm, well, it's very interesting because I noted this as well. I noticed there's a fuzzy purple butterfly frame on the desk and like a tassel lamp that has fireflies on it. So I got a little curious about this. Like what's the story behind this? Did a 12 year old girl decorate this office? Well, I guess in the script, Mike sure had named this character Gwendolyn Trundlebed. Oh my Lord. This is bringing up some Clementine Paddleford memories for me, Angela. Yes. 100% Clementine Paddleford and Gwendolyn Trundlebed are friends in a Disney film. But this woman, we never call her by name. She was played by a background performer. She didn't have any lines. But I guess the set
冷酷无情。你可以看到她脸上那种表情，嗯，很有趣，因为我也注意到了这一点。我注意到桌上有一个毛茸茸的紫色蝴蝶相框，还有一个上面有萤火虫的流苏台灯。所以我对此有点好奇。这背后有什么故事吗？难道是一个12岁的小女孩装修了这间办公室吗？好吧，我想在剧本里，迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）给这个角色取名叫格温多伦·特伦德尔贝德（Gwendolyn Trundlebed）。哦，天哪。这让我想起了克莱门汀·帕德尔福德（Clementine Paddleford）的回忆，安吉拉。是的。100%，克莱门汀·帕德尔福德和格温多伦·特伦德尔贝德就像是迪士尼电影里的好朋友。不过这个女人，我们从没叫过她的名字。她是由一个背景演员扮演的。她没有任何台词。但我想布景
decorators, they really took it to heart and they were inspired by the name Gwendolyn Trundlebed. And that is why the office looks the way it does. Well, it works perfectly because Dwight, I feel like is coming in there with all this sort of like macho energy and he came into Gwendolyn Trundlebed's boudoir of pinkness. That's what it looks like. It's very boudoir looking. Eventually, we find out that Dwight lands at Staples. He says it's temporary while he continues his job search. Remember, Staples is Dunder Mifflin's big competitor. They're their big rival, I know. Yeah. But then back at the office, Andy has taken Dwight's seat across from Jim. Yeah. Yeah. And he's really proud of the ringtone. We talked about it with Ed, but he is very proud
师们真的是走心了，他们从“格温多伦·特伦德尔贝德”这个名字中获得了灵感。这就是为什么办公室看起来是这个样子的。好吧，这效果完美极了，因为我觉得德怀特带着各种各样的大男子主义能量闯了进去，结果却走进了格温多伦·特伦德尔贝德的粉色闺房。看起来就是这样。非常有闺房的感觉。最终，我们发现德怀特落脚在了史泰博（Staples）。他说这只是暂时的，他还要继续找工作。记住，史泰博可是邓德·米夫林的大竞争对手。他们是死对头，我懂的。对啊。但转回到办公室里，安迪已经坐上了德怀特原本坐在吉姆对面的座位。对啊。对啊。而且他为自己的手机铃声感到无比骄傲。我们跟艾德聊过这个，但他真的非常骄傲
that he did all four parts of the harmony. And I don't know music, Jenna. I don't even know what you call it. I have to tell you, I still, I know we talked about this with Ed, but it's still, it's incredibly impressive. I mean, it's so impressive. I mean, Aka Pella is really impressive. Aka what? Yeah. I just said it because there's one guy that's like bing, bong, bong, bong, bong, bing, bong. You know what I mean? Yeah. And then there's another person that's like, la, la, la, like, I don't get it. But it sounded amazing. I still can't believe he did that himself. One of the things I love about the scene, obviously, how much Andy's annoying everyone already, but he calls Ryan big turkey. Yeah. Does that mean that Ryan eats turkey sandwiches for
自己把和声的四个部分全都唱出来了。我不懂音乐，珍娜。我甚至不知道你们管这叫什么。我得告诉你，我依然，我知道我们跟艾德聊过这个，但这还是，让人印象深刻得难以置信。我是说，真的太令人印象深刻了。我是说，阿卡贝拉（Acapella）真的很厉害。阿卡什么？对啊。我这么说是因为里面有个家伙声音是“兵，邦，邦，邦，邦，兵，邦”。你知道我的意思吗？对啊。然后另一个人是“啦，啦，啦”这样的，我不懂。但听起来太棒了。我还是不敢相信那是他自己一个人录的。我喜欢这个场景的地方之一，显然是安迪已经把所有人都惹烦了，但他管瑞恩叫“大火鸡”。对啊。这是不是意味着瑞恩午餐总是吃
lunch? It has to. It has to. What are we learning here? Well, clearly, I mean, Andy had a friend called Broccoli Rob. Do you know what I mean? Yes. All of the nicknames are just what you eat. Yeah. I'm Yogurt Pam. I'd be Donut Kinsey. Well, in real life. Oh, in real life. Yes. I guess I'd be eggs and strawberries, Fisher. That's catchy. Jenna, I feel like there is a very classic Jim Pam shot that we have to talk about. What is it? It's at one minute, 58 seconds. Andy is singing the ridiculous version of Andy and the tuna, you know, that whole part? Yes. Yes. And the camera focuses on Jim's reaction and then pushes past Jim and Jim goes out of focus and it lands on Pam. And they both have similar expressions of like, Oh my God, this guy. And
火鸡三明治？肯定是。必须是。我们在这学到了什么？好吧，很明显，安迪有个朋友叫西兰花罗布（Broccoli Rob）。你知道我的意思吗？是的。所有的绰号都只是根据你吃的东西来取的。对啊。我是酸奶帕姆。我要是金西甜甜圈。好吧，在现实生活中。哦，在现实生活中。是的。我想我会是Fisher牌的鸡蛋和草莓。听起来很顺口。珍娜，我觉得有一个非常经典的吉姆和帕姆的镜头，我们必须聊聊。是什么？就在1分钟58秒的时候。安迪正在唱那个荒谬版本的安迪和金枪鱼，你知道，就那整段？是的。是的。然后镜头聚焦在吉姆的反应上，接着越过吉姆，吉姆虚焦了，镜头落在了帕姆身上。他们俩都有着相似的表情，仿佛在说：“哦，天哪，这家伙。”而
for me, I don't know. I know I love Jim and Pam so much. So I don't know if I'm like looking for meaning. But in that moment, I'm like, they're on the same page. These two are both in it. Like they're going to be in it together for this episode because it's putting them the same way. Yes. I think this is that first hint that they are in sync. I think so. And it was just also a beautiful shot just to be a technical nerd. Like that is a beautiful shot. I agree. Well, now Michael arrives to work and he's parked his car. His, you know what? His roof won't go up, but who cares? It's fine. He's going to leave it. Nope. It's not going to be a problem. That could be a big deal on the biggest snow day they've had. I watched this episode with my kids.
对我来说，我不知道。我知道我太爱吉姆和帕姆了。所以我不知道我是不是在过度寻找意义。但在那一刻，我觉得：他们俩的想法完全合拍。这两个人都在状态里，就像他们在这集里要同心协力一样，因为镜头把他们放在了同一个视角。是的。我觉得这是他们俩心灵相通的第一个暗示。我也这么觉得。而且从技术宅的角度来看，这也是一个非常漂亮的镜头。就像那真是一个绝妙的镜头。我同意。好了，现在迈克尔来上班了，他把车停好了。他的，你懂的，他的车顶打不开了，但谁在乎呢？没关系。他打算就这么把车扔那儿了。不。这绝不会出问题。在他们遇到过最大的一场大雪天里，这可说不准是个大问题。我和我孩子一起看的这一集。
I know I talked about that. They loved his hair. They loved how his hair was just messy from getting out of his car. I didn't even notice that. That's such a good detail. I know. I know. They catch a few things. I'm going to sprinkle them through. I love that. Well, Oscar arrives next to Michael and he is welcomed back by Michael. Yeah. Michael says, hey, nice new car. And Oscar said, well, I got this new car in the settlement after you kissed me at work. I love how matter of factly Oscar says it. That Lexus SUV. That's all you buddy. And then Michael's like, well, that's how we do it here at Dunder Mifflin. When we settle,
我知道我之前说过这个。他们太喜欢他的发型了。他们喜欢他刚下车时那把蓬乱的头发。我甚至都没注意到这一点。这真是一个绝妙的细节。我知道。我知道。他们总能捕捉到一些小细节。我会在节目里时不时分享一下。我太喜欢了。好吧，奥斯卡紧跟着迈克尔到达了，迈克尔对他的回归表示了欢迎。对啊。迈克尔说：“嘿，不错的新车。”奥斯卡则说：“哦，这是你在办公室强吻我之后，我和解拿到的赔偿金买的新车。”我喜欢奥斯卡那种一本正经的语气。那辆雷克萨斯SUV。全靠你了，老兄。然后迈克尔就说：“好吧，我们邓德·米夫林就是这么办事的。既然要和解，
we settle high. And then Oscar has that great talking head where he says, part of him wants people in the office to have learned their lesson and to shut the hell up, but another part of him wants them to keep talking so he can buy a home theater. So now we go into Michael's office and Jenna, it's one of those classic scenes that you and I love where it starts with Michael and who else is in the room you don't know and then it's revealed. And this time it's Andy. Andy is taking the spot of Dwight over Michael's shoulder, but he's creeping Michael out. You can already tell. Well, there's a way that Michael is always kind of annoyed
我们就得争取最高赔偿。”接着奥斯卡就有了那个超棒的独白镜头，他说，他一方面希望办公室里的人能吸取教训，闭上他们该死的嘴；但另一方面，他又希望他们继续说下去，这样他就能买得起家庭影院了。现在我们进入迈克尔的办公室，珍娜，这是你和我都很喜欢的那种经典场景：开始时只有迈克尔，然后房间里还有谁你并不知道，接着才揭晓。而这次是安迪。安迪取代了德怀特的位置，站在迈克尔身后的肩膀旁，但他已经让迈克尔感到毛骨悚然了。你已经能看出来了。好吧，迈克尔通常都会有点心烦，
when Dwight interjects in the middle of what Michael is saying, but this is different. Like Michael's annoyed by Dwight, but Michael like really is annoyed by Andy. Well, you know what it feels like to me like Andy is getting under his skin. Like Dwight is like an annoying brother, but Andy is like the creeper that lives down the street. I don't know that you try to avoid when you go to the mailbox. Well, we have a fan question in this scene from Tenille who wants to know in this episode, there are a lot of talking heads with Michael facing the window where it's snowing. Were those talking heads shot in sequence so that they didn't have to keep turning the snow on and off?
每当德怀特在迈克尔说话说到一半时插话，但这次不一样。就像迈克尔是被德怀特烦到，但迈克尔对安迪是真的感到厌烦。好吧，你知道这给我的感觉是什么吗？就像安迪正在逐渐惹恼他。德怀特就像是一个烦人的兄弟，而安迪就像是住在街区里的怪胎。我不知道，就是你每次去邮箱拿信时都想刻意避开的那种人。好吧，我们在这一场戏里有一个来自泰妮尔（Tenille）的粉丝提问，她想知道在这集里，有很多迈克尔面对着下雪的窗户的独白镜头。这些独白镜头是一气呵成拍完的吗，这样他们就不用一直开关人工降雪了？
Yes. Yes. I love this question, Angela, because we've never really talked about this. We always shot all of our talking heads in a row. So what they would do is they would set up the shot, let's say in Michael's office for a talking head and every talking head he had for that episode, they would spend hours doing all of them. And the same thing in the conference room. Remember, they'd set up the chair and we would all cycle in for hours and do our talking heads. Yes. It would literally be like talking head day on set. And I always really felt for Steve because he always had the most. And I would think like, oh my God, I had to like learn one, you know, and maybe they would give me some alts on the day.
是的。是的。我太喜欢这个问题了，安吉拉，因为我们从来没有真正聊过这个。我们通常会把所有的独白镜头放在一起连着拍。所以他们会怎么做呢，他们会布置好镜头，比如在迈克尔的办公室里拍独白，然后他那一集所有的独白，他们会花上几个小时把它们全部拍完。会议室里也是一样。记住，他们会把椅子摆好，然后我们所有人会轮流进去呆上几个小时，拍完各自的独白。是的。那字面意思上就像是片场的“独白日”。我一直真的很心疼史蒂夫，因为他的台词总是最多的。我当时就会想：“哦，天哪，我得背会一条，你知道的，也许他们当天还会给我一些备选台词。”
But Steve had to learn so many and just sit there and do them and do them. And Vada would be there, our script supervisor, and sometimes she would remind you if you had more than one, okay, now remember, this talking head is after Dwight left. So you're more sad than the one before, you know? So sometimes she was helping us kind of navigate the time sequence of it all. Yes. And we would usually do these either first thing in the morning or at the end of the day. Steve would always do his first thing in the morning. I think he liked to lead with them. He would oftentimes, I feel like on a Monday, it would be like Steve talking heads until almost lunch. And then we would all come in and film like group scenes for the rest
但史蒂夫必须背下那么多台词，然后就坐在那儿一遍又一遍地拍。瓦达（Vada）也在现场，她是我们的场记，有时如果你有不止一条台词，她会提醒你：“好了，记住，这段独白发生在德怀特离开之后。所以你要比之前那段表现得更难过一点，你知道吗？”所以有时她会帮我们梳理整个时间线。是的。而且我们通常要么把这些安排在清晨一上班，要么在一天快结束的时候。史蒂夫总是会在清晨一上班就拍这些。我觉得他喜欢开工就先搞定这些。通常我觉得在周一的时候，差不多直到快吃午饭前，都一直在拍史蒂夫的独白。然后我们所有人会在剩下的时间里来拍摄群戏。
of the day. Yeah. But then on Fridays, we would spend Friday afternoons, all the rest of the cast doing our talking heads. That was kind of how we framed our week. Yeah, that's how I remember it too. Well, Jenna, you know, Oscar's back now and he walks back over to accounting. And of course, Kevin has a ridiculous joke that he's been saving for weeks. Kevin thought of it. He was like, how is your gaycation? Oscar's like, awesome. Kevin's like, yeah, I thought of that two seconds after you left. Kevin's so proud of himself. And Angela is just like, hello. And he's like, hello. And you can tell that there's, I feel like a lot she wants to say, but she's not, she's not ready yet. She doesn't know how to say it yet. Yeah. But then eventually Angela does invite Oscar to join the
是的。但到了周五，我们会把周五下午的时间花在剩下的所有演员身上来拍摄各自的独白。这就是我们安排一周工作节奏的方式。是的，我的记忆也是这样的。好吧，珍娜，你知道的，奥斯卡现在回来了，他走回了会计部。当然了，凯文有个他憋了好几周的荒谬笑话。凯文自己想出来的。他当时说：“你的‘同性恋假期’（gaycation）过得怎么样？”奥斯卡说：“棒极了。”凯文就说：“对啊，在你离开两秒钟后我就想到了。”凯文觉得自己可骄傲了。而安吉拉只是：“你好。”然后他回了句：“你好。”你可以看出，我觉得她心里有很多话想说，但她还没准备好。她还不知道该怎么说出口。是的。不过后来安吉拉确实邀请了奥斯卡加入
party planning committee. She says she's sorry for the way certain things transpired and she wants to make some changes and she starts crying. Yeah. Well, Jenna, I really cried. That was me really crying. And I had a whole conversation with Greg about it as we were trying to find the scene. And I did one take and he was like, Angela, I'm feeling sad. And he said, this has to be a funny cry where sometimes on a show, someone cries and it breaks your heart. He said, this needs to be just awkward. Like, and then at the end, we have a joke because Kevin says, can I join? And I say, never. Right? Right. So, so it was sort of this interesting thing of figuring out how do you cry, but you don't make people feel bad, you know? So, so, and what really helped me was that my
派对筹备委员会。她说她为某些事情发生的方式感到抱歉，她想做出一些改变，然后她开始哭了起来。好吧，珍娜，我当时真的是在哭。那真的是我在哭。我和格雷格进行了整整一番对话，当时我们正在琢磨这场戏的感觉。我拍了一条，然后他说：“安吉拉，我感觉有点悲伤。”他说，这必须是一种好笑的哭，有时候在剧里，某人哭了会让你心碎。他说，这里需要表现得有点尴尬。然后最后我们有个包袱，因为凯文说：“我能加入吗？”我说：“绝不。”对吧？对吧？所以，这就变成了一种很有意思的事情，去琢磨你该怎么哭，但又不能让别人觉得难受，你知道吗？所以，而真正帮到我的是，我的
lines were so ridiculous. So it was, you know, me being like, certain events transpired and certain people and certain things, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah. But it was sort of this art for my character to find a way to cry that was just more awkward than sad. Well, you just made someone very happy. Sarah Cooper had written in to ask you, did you have to do anything different to get into character in preparation for this episode? You know, when you cry, we all have a little bit of our process of actors of how we get to that place. But it was this sort of interesting thing to get myself there, but then kind of pull back a little bit. And this might be really boring, actory stuff, but it was a really interesting exercise. Well, we had another fan question,
台词实在太荒谬了。所以就是我一直在说：“某些事件发生了，某些人和某些事，你知道我的意思吗？”对啊，对啊。但这对于我的角色来说，算是一种艺术，需要找到一种哭法，比起悲伤，它其实更显尴尬。好吧，你刚刚让某个人非常高兴。萨拉·库珀（Sarah Cooper）曾写信问过你，在准备拍摄这一集时，为了进入角色，你有没有做过什么特别的准备？你知道的，当你哭泣时，我们演员都有自己的一套小方法来让自己进入那种情绪。但要让自己进入那个状态，然后又稍微收敛一点，这是一个很有意思的过程。这可能听起来是很枯燥的演员理论，但真的是一次非常有趣的练习。好吧，我们还有另一个粉丝提问，
Angela, from Beatrix Smith. Was it weird for you to have Oscar back? Did you miss him when he was gone? Oh, yeah, I think Angela definitely missed Oscar. Listen, him being gone means, A, she's carrying most of the workload and accounting because Kevin's no help, really. And I think that Oscar and Angela really are these sort of mismatched roommates, if you will. And you'll see their friendship come through throughout the seasons. But they are there for each other. It's just, I think they just had some hurdles to get over. Oh, well, that's a nice answer. I think she met you, Angela. Did you miss your friend, Oscar, who hadn't been sitting there with you? But I like, I like how you stayed in character there for that answer.
安吉拉，来自贝特里克斯·史密斯（Beatrix Smith）。奥斯卡回来对你来说奇怪吗？他不在的时候你想他吗？哦，对啊，我觉得安吉拉绝对是想念奥斯卡的。听着，他不在意味着，第一，会计部的大部分工作都要落在她一个人头上，因为凯文根本帮不上忙。而且我觉得奥斯卡和安吉拉真的就像是那种性格不搭的室友，如果你愿意这么形容的话。你会看到他们的友谊在接下来的几季中逐渐显现出来。但他们会在关键时刻支持彼此。只是，我觉得他们之间确实需要跨过一些障碍。哦，好吧，这回答得真好。我觉得她问的是你，安吉拉。你想念你的朋友奥斯卡吗，那个以前没坐在你身边的人？不过我喜欢，我喜欢你刚才为了回答这个问题而一直保持在角色状态里。
Well, we were talking so much about Angela Martin. Well, of course I missed my friend. Are you kidding? I didn't have anyone to draw me little crazy cartoons of myself being silly and passing me notes. But it was- You guys are such a little trio over there. Yeah, I definitely missed them. Well, while all of this is going on, Andy is just stalking Michael. Yeah, he's like looking for him everywhere and he follows him to the bathroom. Yeah. Jenna, Andy now has two expressions that I love. We first heard Nifty Gifties from Andy. Love me the Nifty Gifties. And in this one, Michael's like, what's up? And Andy goes, Nerfin. Nerfin. Nerfin. And now me and my kids are saying Nerfin. It just, it has stuck here at the house.
好吧，我们刚刚一直在聊安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）。好吧，我当然想念我的朋友了。你在开玩笑吗？我都没人可以画一些关于我自己的疯狂搞笑漫画，然后偷偷传纸条给我了。不过这——你们俩在那边简直就像是个小三人组。对啊，我绝对想念他们。好吧，就在这一切都在发生的同时，安迪一直在跟踪迈克尔。对啊，他到处找迈克尔，甚至还尾随他去了洗手间。是的。珍娜，安迪现在有两个我特别喜欢的口头禅。我们第一次听到安迪说“超赞礼物”（Nifty Gifties）的时候。“我太爱超赞礼物了。”而在这一集里，迈克尔问“怎么了”，安迪就说：“没什么（Nerfin）。”没什么。没什么。现在我和我的孩子们也开始说“Nerfin”了。它就这么在我们家流传下来了。
I thought it was so funny. But yeah, Andy's driving Michael crazy. And Michael has a whole talking head from behind his door. He's hiding. It was, it made me laugh out loud because I didn't know where he was during this because Andy's looking for him and he's just nowhere. He's nowhere. And then when he's revealed to be giving this whole talking head from behind his door, one of the things I loved about it most was that while hiding, he was still compelled to perform and speak to the camera. Yeah. He was like, I'm hiding, but I'm not going to stop presenting myself to this camera crew. I wonder if he was like, I'm going to hide and you have to too. Because if Andy sees you guys in here, so like, is there a way where the camera crew is like
我觉得这太搞笑了。不过，对啊，安迪把迈克尔逼疯了。迈克尔甚至躲在门后面录了一段独白。他在躲猫猫。这让我忍不住哈哈大笑，因为我甚至不知道他在拍这段的时候躲哪儿去了，因为安迪到处找他，结果他哪儿都不在。他根本不在。然后当揭晓他居然是躲在门后录这段独白时，最让我觉得好笑的一点是，哪怕在躲藏的时候，他依然忍不住要在镜头前表演和说话。对啊。他就像是：“我在躲，但我才不会停止向这个摄像团队展现自我呢。”我在想他当时会不会在想：“我要躲起来，你们也得跟着躲。如果安迪在这儿看到你们……”所以，难道摄像组当时也是
smushed up against the wall also hiding? That's such a good point. Like all Andy has to look for is like, where's the camera pointed? Yeah. There's a crew constantly following Michael around. Well, we're coming up on a scene that completely destroyed John Krasinski in real life. I don't think he's ever laughed so hard ever, ever on the show. He has said it's the hardest he laughed the whole series. Like, and I texted Creed about it. Yeah, it's this scene in the kitchen where Oscar comes in and he's just kind of like, where's Dwight? And Creed says Dwight was decapitated and they had a funeral for a bird. Which is not correct. But kind of correct. Just all munched up together.
整个人紧紧贴在墙上也跟着躲藏吗？这真是个绝妙的点子！安迪只需要看摄像机正对着哪儿就行了。对啊。有一个摄制组一直在到处跟着迈克尔。好吧，我们接下来要看到的一场戏，在现实生活中彻底把约翰·卡拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）给击溃了。我觉得他在整部剧里从来没笑得这么夸张过。他说这是整整五季里他笑得最厉害的一次。而且我还为此给克里德（Creed）发了信息。对啊，就是厨房里的那场戏，奥斯卡走进来，随口问了句“德怀特去哪儿了”，然后克里德说德怀特被斩首了，他们还为一只鸟举办了葬礼。这完全不对。但又好像沾点边。
Yeah. Ed Truck was decapitated and they did have a funeral for a bird. And remember, Jim wasn't around for any of this. So Jim isn't even able to like correct this. So he just says, I'm pretty sure that's not real. And then Creed says, you're not real man. And that is the line that destroyed John Krasinski. Yeah. John could not keep it together. He crumbled like into just fits of laughter. And I texted Creed. I was like, Creed, oh my gosh, we're breaking down the return. And you have that great line that you said to John and he was like, I said, what was that like? He said, oh, Ange, it was so much fun to see John lose it like that. He said, he lost it.
把两件事全混到一块儿了。对啊。是艾德·特克（Ed Truck）被斩首了，而他们确实为一只鸟举行了葬礼。记住，吉姆当时根本不在现场经历这些。所以吉姆甚至都没法纠正这个错误。于是他只能说：“我敢确定那不是真的。”然后克里德说：“你才不是真的，老兄。”就是这句台词把约翰·卡拉辛斯基给彻底击溃了。对啊。约翰根本控制不住自己。他笑到整个人直接崩溃，完全笑作一团。我还给克里德发了短信。我问：“克里德，哦天哪，我们在回顾《回归》这一集呢。你有那句对约翰说的超棒台词。”然后他说：“我问他当时是什么感觉。”克里德说：“哦，安吉，看约翰笑成那样可太好玩了。”他说：“他彻底笑崩了。”
There are a couple of times on the show where John has laughed so hard that like, you can't. You just can't even film him because when he really loses it, he cannot be brought back. He can't. He's like he is what we said. He is destroyed. He's destroyed. He doubles over. He kind of tears up. He can't make noise. It was laughing like that. And I said, Creed, I mean, how did you how many takes did you do? And he said, I think we got one where he kept it together. I think that's the one they used. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. So now we have this little scene where Michael is noticing that like the plant in the office is dying. He says, you need to talk to the cleaning crew about this. And also while you're at it, they used to arrange the
剧里有好几次，约翰笑得太厉害了，以至于你根本没办法拍他，因为当他真正笑崩的时候，根本就缓不过来。他真的不行。他就像我们刚才说的。他被击溃了。他整个人笑得蜷缩起来。他甚至有点热泪盈眶。他连声音都发不出来。他就是这么笑的。然后我对克里德说：“我是说，你们拍了多少条？”他说：“我想我们拍出了一条他忍住没笑场的。我想他们用的就是那条。”对啊。确实如此。所以现在我们有了这样一个小片段：迈克尔注意到办公室里的植物快要枯萎了。他说：“你得跟清洁团队谈谈这件事。还有，顺便一提，他们以前会把
toys on my desk in this really pleasing way. And I need to know why they've stopped. And Pam is like, well, no, that was Dwight. No, Dwight used to do that. And then of course, up from out of nowhere comes Andy. And he's like, I agree. And Michael's like, what are we, how do you know? What do you agree with? How do you even know what we're talking about? Yeah. And Andy's like, Pam was like, blah, blah, something lame. And then you're like, ready to do. Right. There it is. There it is. Come on. Seven minutes, 33 seconds. The very first, but not the last, ridded it to do. So we're back at the party planning committee meeting. Angela is sad. She is sad. She's not even speaking up about anything. She's not even being mean to Phyllis. You know,
我桌上的玩具以一种非常赏心悦目的方式摆好，我得知道他们为什么不这么干了。”然后帕姆就说：“哦，不，那是德怀特。不，德怀特以前总是那样做。”接着，当然了，安迪不知从哪儿突然冒了出来。他说：“我同意。”迈克尔就说：“我们在干嘛，你怎么知道的？你同意什么？你甚至怎么知道我们在聊什么？”对啊。然后安迪就说：“帕姆刚才说，巴拉巴拉，挺无聊的。”然后你就说：“准备……”好了。就是这句。就在这儿。7分钟33秒。第一次，但绝不是最后一次的“准备做这做那”（riddit-dit-do）。所以我们回到了派对筹备委员会的会议上。安吉拉很难过。她很难过。她甚至都没对任何事情发表意见。她甚至都没对菲利斯（Phyllis）刻薄。你知道的，
the woman is sad. Can I say something? Yeah. I think that later when we see this party, it's going to be one of the best ones we've ever thrown. How dare you? I'm just saying, I'm just saying that you're a little checked out and look what we did without you. When we, when others were allowed to participate in the planning, we threw a very like the decorations that Creed loved the food. Let me tell you something, lady. What? What? I am flabbergasted. Well, I mean, I just want to say I noted, I noted how disengaged from the planning Angela was, and then I noticed what a really great party it was. Well, you know, Michael has given the marching orders. He really wants to celebrate Oscar as Michael says, quote, his Mexicanness.
这女人太难过了。我能说句话吗？对啊。我觉得稍后当我们看到这个派对时，这将是我们办过的最棒的派对之一。你怎么敢这么说？我只是说，我只是说你有点状况外，看看没有你我们办得多好。当我们，当其他人也被允许参与筹划时，我们办了一个非常——克里德超喜欢那些装饰和食物。我跟你讲个事儿，女士。什么？什么？我简直惊呆了。好吧，我的意思是，我只想说我注意到，安吉拉对筹划工作的参与度实在是太低了，然后我发现这其实是个非常棒的派对。好吧，你知道的，迈克尔已经下达了指令。他真的很想庆祝奥斯卡，正如迈克尔所说，引用原话：“他的墨西哥风情”。
He wants firecrackers, a Chihuahua. You know, he also tells them to get a donkey. A borough. Because, you know, the reason that we're throwing a Mexican theme party is because Oscar's gayness does not define him. His Mexicanness is what defines him. And Oscar's just like, according to Michael. Great. Great. Right back in it with Michael. Oscar's thinking of all the things he's going to purchase after this party. I know. Well, I have a question for you about a scene coming up, Jenna. Okay, in the script that Andy like fishes for Jim, like that he throws the rod and reel and the whole thing? Or was that just made up on the day? Angela, I will, I will check the script for that. And in the meantime, while
他想要爆竹、吉娃娃。你知道的，他还吩咐他们去弄头驴。一头小毛驴（borough）。因为，你知道的，我们举办墨西哥主题派对的原因是，奥斯卡的同性恋身份并不能定义他。他的墨西哥风情才是定义他的东西。而奥斯卡的反应就是：听迈克尔的呗。太棒了。太棒了。又跟迈克尔的脑回路对上了。奥斯卡甚至在盘算着办完这个派对后他要买些什么东西。我知道。好吧，我有一个关于接下来某个场景的问题要问你，珍娜。好吧，在剧本里，安迪会像钓鱼一样甩竿钓吉姆，就是他真的甩出鱼竿和卷线器的那个动作？还是那是当天即兴发挥出来的？安吉拉，我会的，我会去查一下剧本。在此期间，
I'm doing that, please enjoy this whole music by Carmen and Camille doing their version of Heartbreak in the Breakroom. One moment. All right. Thank you for holding. I could not find that in the script. It wasn't in the script. No. So it was either conceived of as a rewrite page or it was something he did on the day. So what's in the script? The thing that makes Jim want to prank Andy is just more singing at his desk, that he's just obnoxiously singing. And then Jim decides he has to do something. Right. But the fishing for tuna, not in the script. Okay. Well, it's perfect for Andy. It's so perfect. Jim has had it though. And he now wants to play prank. He
在我查剧本的时候，请大家欣赏由卡门（Carmen）和卡米尔（Camille）带来的他们版本的《休息室里的心碎》（Heartbreak in the Breakroom）。请稍等。好啦。谢谢久等。我在剧本里没找到这段。剧本里并没有。所以，要么是后来作为重写页补充进去的，要么就是他在现场即兴发挥的。那剧本里写的是什么？让吉姆想要捉弄安迪的原因，仅仅是他在办公桌旁唱得更多了，他在那儿极其惹人生厌地唱歌。然后吉姆决定他必须做点什么。没错。但是拿鱼竿钓金枪鱼，并不在剧本里。好吧。这太符合安迪的性格了。简直太完美了。不过吉姆已经受够了。他现在想捉弄对方。他
asked Karen. Karen says she's too busy. She got all of Dwight's clients. Then he asked Ryan. And lady, we have some Ryan sass. I loved it. I'm falling in love with Ryan. I know you are. Not going to lie. I know you are. What does he say? I'll tell you what he said. He says, oh, you know what? Not right now, but ask me again 10 years ago. And I feel like John's, the look on John's face as Jim in that moment is so good. So good. He's like, all right, man. I liked you better when you were the temp. Ryan's like, so did I. So did I. That's some serious Ryan sass. So Angela, should we check in with Dwight now? See how he's doing over at Staples? Yes. He's doing great. He's crushing it. He is. We had some
去问了凯伦（Karen）。凯伦说她太忙了。她接手了德怀特所有的客户。然后他又去问了瑞恩。而天哪，我们看到了满满的瑞恩式毒舌。我太喜欢了。我简直要爱上瑞恩了。我知道你很喜欢。说实话。我知道你很喜欢。他说了什么？我来告诉你他是怎么说的。他说：“哦，你知道吗？现在不行，不过十年后再来问我吧。”我觉得约翰在那个时刻作为吉姆露出的那个表情太棒了。太棒了。他就那种：“好吧，老兄。”我还是更喜欢你当临时工的时候。瑞恩就说：“我也是。我也是。”这绝对是高级别的瑞恩式毒舌。所以，安吉拉，我们要不要现在去看看德怀特？看看他在史泰博过得怎么样？好啊。他过得好极了。他简直大获成功。确实。我们收到了许多
fan questions about Staples from Amy Jackson, Aaron Westra, Ainsley Thompson, Jeff Needham, Diamond P, and Kate N. They wanted to know, did we film in an actual Staples store? Yes. Yes, we did. We filmed at a real Staples. It was at the Empire Center in Burbank. I've actually been there many times, not only to the Empire Center, but to this actual Staples. I have purchased my home printer at this Staples. Jenna, I feel like we went there for like a BFF afternoon where we went to Target and then we went to Staples together. I have like a memory of that. Oh, yeah. I'm sure we did that because then there's that donut place that you like. What is it? Krispy Kreme. Krispy Kreme, what's not to like? Exactly. And they have a drive-thru. They have a
关于史泰博的粉丝提问，来自艾米·杰克逊（Amy Jackson）、阿伦·维斯特拉（Aaron Westra）、艾恩斯利·汤普森（Ainsley Thompson）、杰夫·尼德姆（Jeff Needham）、戴蒙德·P（Diamond P）和凯特·N（Kate N）。他们想知道，我们是在真正的史泰博门店里取景拍摄的吗？是的。是的，我们是。我们在一家真正的史泰博拍的。位于伯班克的帝国中心（Empire Center）。其实我去过那里很多次，不仅去过帝国中心，还去过这家真正的史泰博。我的家用打印机就是在里买的。珍娜，我觉得我们以前去那里度过一个闺蜜下午，先去了塔吉特（Target），然后一起去了史泰博。我脑海里好像还有这段记忆。哦，对啊。我敢肯定我们去过，因为那边有一家你很喜欢的甜甜圈店。叫什么来着？Krispy Kreme（克里斯比克里姆）。Krispy Kreme，谁能不爱呢？没错。而且他们还有得开车点餐的得来速（drive-thru）。他们有
drive-thru. They have a drive-thru and they also have this conveyor belt that you can watch. It's like watching a car wash, but it's donuts going by and then you get to the end and they just take it right off the conveyor belt and it's super warm and they hand it to you and kids love it. It's like a mini donut factory. Well, I would take my kids there all the time. I think that the first time we went, you and I didn't even have kids. Well, this is true. This is true. Okay. So yeah, Dwight is crushing it. Sorry, we got off on a tangent about donuts. Go figure. We did. But I want to say, remember back in the merger when we talked about how Staples paid the production to feature one of its shredders in an
得来速，而且他们还有一个你可以观看的传送带。就像看洗车一样，但过去的是甜甜圈，然后走到尽头，他们直接从传送带上拿下来，热乎乎的，然后递给你，小孩子们都超爱。这就像是一个迷你的甜甜圈工厂。好吧，我以前总是带我的孩子们去那儿。我觉得我们第一次去的时候，你和我甚至都还没有孩子。好吧，这倒也是。这是真的。好吧。所以，对啊，德怀特简直干得风生水起。抱歉，我们刚才扯到甜甜圈上去了。可见一斑。确实扯远了。不过我想说，还记得之前在公司合并时，我们聊过史泰博是如何花钱赞助剧组，让它的一台碎纸机在某一集里出镜吗？
episode. People were asking if this was still part of that product integration. No. No, this was just a plot point. They just thought it would be funny that Dwight ends up going to work for Dunder Mifflin's competitor. So Staples did not pay to be featured in this episode at all. And then, guess what they did? What? They did something insane to the Staples. What'd they do? So I'm going to let Greg tell you. We arranged to have real Staples be the location for this episode. And I had scouted it. And then between the time that I scouted it and the time that we showed up to shoot, they had replaced all the Staples signage with very unrealistic looking Staples signs that were three times bigger than what we had seen because they wanted more of an advertising
人们都在问这是否仍然是那种产品植入的一部分。并不是。不，这只是一个剧情需要。他们只是觉得让德怀特去邓德·米夫林的竞争对手那里工作会很有趣。所以史泰博根本没有花钱在这集里露脸。然后，你猜他们做了什么？什么？他们对那家史泰博做了一件疯狂的事。他们干嘛了？那我让格雷格来告诉你吧。我们安排了真正的史泰博作为这一集的取景地。我之前去踩过点。然后就在我踩点和我们现身拍摄之间，他们把所有的史泰博招牌都换成了看起来非常不真实的史泰博标志，比我们之前看到的要大上整整三倍，因为他们希望在早晨我们准备开拍时，能在我们剧的背景里看到更多的广告
pop in the background of our show in the morning of the day we were supposed to shoot there. And so it became like a thing about, you know, we had to make our day and we had to shoot, but I didn't want to turn the show into an ad for Staples. So there was a lot of shooting around it. And I believe the last shot where the camera kind of zooms into a security camera to see them exiting was to avoid a gigantic Staples sign that they had put up at the last minute. Ooh, Staples. You were so sneaky. Oh, Staples. Can you blame them? They're like, hey, we got a camera crew here. I'm going to put up my big sign. I'd probably do the same thing. I would do the same thing. They were like, Henry, get over here. Bring the tall ladder and the big
植入效果。所以这就变成了一个问题，你知道的，我们必须赶进度完成当天的拍摄，但我又不想把这部剧变成史泰博的广告。所以有很多镜头都是绕着拍的。我相信最后一个镜头——摄像机拉近到一个安全摄像头上去看他们离开的那一幕，就是为了避开他们临时挂上去的那个巨大的史泰博招牌。哦，史泰博。你们可真会搞小动作。哦，史泰博。你能怪他们吗？他们大概在想：“嘿，这儿有个摄制组呢。我要把我的大招牌挂上去。”我要是他们我可能也会这么做。我也会这么做。他们当时大概在喊：“亨利，过来！把高梯子和大招牌拿来。”
signs. Yeah. Get it on TV. You know I love the Staples folks because they give back to teachers, Jenna. So oh, yeah, I love them. But that is very funny. I have a little piece of trivia though about that day. Dave Rogers said that Greg got really sick that day. So sick that he had to go home halfway through the day and Randall took over. Whoa. Yeah. That's crazy. I know. Well, listen, I want to talk a little bit about Dwight's new coworker Paris. She's amazing. Played by Yvette Nicole Brown, who would later go to star in community. This scene with them in the break room eating lunch, I watched it three times. I watched it three times because she is so funny. Her, like, you know what it is? I feel like we're getting this
对啊。把它弄上电视。你知道我超喜欢史泰博的员工，因为他们会回馈老师，珍娜。所以哦，对啊，我超爱他们。但那个真的超级搞笑。不过关于那一天，我还有一个小小幕后趣闻。戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）说，格雷格那天病得很重。病得甚至不得不在拍摄进行到一半时就回家了，然后由兰德尔（Randall）接替了导演工作。哇。对啊。太疯狂了。我知道。好吧，听着，我想聊聊德怀特的全新同事帕里斯（Paris）。她太棒了。由伊薇特·尼科尔·BROWN（Yvette Nicole Brown）饰演，她后来主演了《废柴联盟》（Community）。他们俩在休息室吃午餐的这场戏，我看了整整三遍。我看了三遍，因为她实在是太搞笑了。她，你知道是怎么回事吗？我觉得我们得到了
opportunity to have someone outside of the Dunder Mifflin family react to Dwight's route. We all know what Dwight is like. We know what to expect from him. So to place Dwight in the real world with a regular person who's not used to him was so funny to me and her reactions were what I would imagine anyone would react like if they met Dwight. Yes. I texted her. I said, Yvette, I just want you to know I forgot about this scene and how great it was and rewatching it. It was hilarious. And she was like, Oh, Angela, I feel like I was just there for a blip. And I said, Yvette, you stole the scene. You stole the scene. Yes. Now you mentioned Angela that you were watching this episode with your kids. My son walked into my office while I was watching this
这样一个机会，能让一个邓德·米夫林家族以外的人来对德怀特的种种怪异举止做出真实反应。我们都知道德怀特是什么样的人。我们对他的行为早习以为常了。所以把德怀特放到现实世界中，和一个不习惯他这一套的普通人放在一起，对我来说简直太搞笑了，而她的反应就是我能想象到的任何人遇到德怀特时的真实反应。是的。我给她发了短信。我说：“伊薇特，我只想让你知道，我之前都忘了这场戏以及它有多棒，刚才重看了一遍。简直太爆笑了。”然后她回复说：“哦，安吉拉，我觉得我当时在那儿就只是昙花一现。”我说：“伊薇特，你把整场戏都给偷走了。你抢尽了风头。”是的。现在你提到安吉拉你是和你的孩子们一起看这一集的。我儿子在我看这场戏的时候走进了我的办公室。
scene. He was laughing. And then he and I looked for a fan catch that was sent in by Lori Lex. Oh, what'd you guys find? Oh, my gosh. My son was so tickled because during the scene, Dwight's sandwich that he's eating gets bigger rather than smaller as he eats it. Because they use different takes. So at 12 minutes, 21 seconds, all that's left is like a little corner of bread. And then at 12 minutes, 28 seconds, it's much larger. I love it. I love how into this episode our kids were with background catches. I know. It's so cute. Well, lady, I want to talk about the scene with Michael and Angela. They're in the break room. And they're clearly both missing Dwight. But obviously, neither of them are saying that to each other. And Michael just says,
他笑得不行。然后我和他一起寻找了一个由洛瑞·莱克斯（Lori Lex）发来的粉丝穿帮彩蛋。哦？你们发现了什么？哦，天哪。我儿子觉得可逗了，因为在这场戏里，德怀特正在吃的三明治随着他吃，反而变得越来越大，而不是越来越小。因为他们用了不同的拍摄素材。所以当时间到12分21秒时，剩下的只有一小角面包了；然后到了12分28秒时，三明治明显变大了很多。我太喜欢了。我好喜欢我们的孩子们能这么投入地跟我们一起寻找剧中的背景穿帮。我知道。太可爱了。好吧，老兄，我想聊聊迈克尔和安吉拉的那场戏。他们俩在休息室里。很显然他们俩都在想念德怀特。但显然，他们谁也没有对彼此说出口。迈克尔只是说：
Oh, it's good to have Oscar back. And Angela's like, Yeah, and they both just sort of sadly take a sip of their beverage and look off into space. And I never ever got quiet moment scenes with Steve. And so in rewatching this, it was so special to me, because I just, our characters hardly ever interacted. And when they did, I was usually mad at him, you know? Yeah. So that was really special. And then on a total tangent, there is a fantastic shot at 13 minutes, 47 seconds of Luann's water fountain. And it's there like gurgling away. Lady, I saw the same thing. I saw the same thing. I think that's what was in the background of that kitchen scene in that other episode that we all thought was a fireplace. I think it was Luann's
“哦，奥斯卡回来真好。”然后安吉拉说：“对啊。”接着他们俩只是有点难过地各自喝了一口手里的饮料，然后目光游离地望向远方。我以前从来没有机会和史蒂夫拍过这种安静的对戏。所以在重看的时候，这对我觉得特别珍贵，因为我们的角色几乎从来没有过对手戏。每当有对手戏的时候，我通常都在生他的气，你知道的？对啊。所以这真的特别特别。然后扯开话题说个完全不相干的事，在13分47秒的时候有一个绝妙的镜头，拍的是露安（Luann）的喷泉。它就在那儿咕嘟咕嘟地响着。老兄，我也注意到了。我也看到了。我觉得那就是之前某一集里大家以为是壁炉的那个厨房场景背景里的东西。我觉得那就是露安的
water feature. She had a Zen garden and a water fountain. She did. And they never plugged it in because it made noise. But every once in a while, I guess it got plugged in. And I think you're right because it has a little blue light in it. Yes. That maybe we thought was a fire, something. Yes. Oh my God, I love that we both got excited about Luann's fountain. Well, Jenna, I think on that note of getting super excited about a fountain that in the background, we should take a break. Yeah, we'll take a break and then we'll come back and get into this big prank. All right, guys, we are back. Angela, do you know what I'm doing right now? No, I mean, I can see you, but I'm making bread. I can't see your hands, but I know your left one
水景装置。她有一个禅意花园和一个喷泉。她确实有。而且他们平时从不把它插上电，因为会有噪音。但每隔一段时间，我猜它还是会被插上电。我觉得你说得对，因为它上面有一个小蓝灯。是的。可能我们以前以为那是火苗什么的。哦，天哪，我太喜欢我们俩都对露安的喷泉这么激动了。好吧，珍娜，既然说到为背景里的一个喷泉激动不已，我觉得我们该休息一下了。对啊，我们休息一下，回来之后再来聊聊这个大型恶作剧。好的，伙计们，我们回来了。安吉拉，你知道我现在在干什么吗？没有，我的意思是，我能看到你，但我正在做面包。我看不到你的双手，但我知道你的左手在动。
is moving. No, not I'm not literally making bread in my lap. I'm sitting here podcasting, but I am simultaneously bread making. Like that's the cool thing about bread making is that I have dough that is rising into a little living dough baby that I'm going to put in my oven and turn into crisp, delicious sourdough bread. As we speak, that science is working in my kitchen on my counter right now. During this break, I molded my little dough baby. Oh, yeah. Well, I molded another dough baby. I like to call my belly because I went downstairs and ate a little piece of this. I don't even know what it is that Josh made. It's like some kind of, it tastes like a little square of pecan pie. It's so good. Can we give a plug to Josh's baking page, please? Baking with Josh
不，我不是字面意思上把面包放在膝盖上做。我正坐在着做播客，但我同时也在做面包。这就是做面包最酷的地方，我有一团正在发酵的面团，它就像一个小小的、有生命的面团宝宝，一会儿我把它放进烤箱，就能烤出又脆又美味的酸 sourdough 面包。就在我们说话的同时，这门科学此刻正在我厨房的台面上发酵呢。在这个休息时间里，我把我的面团宝宝给塑形了。哦，对啊。好吧，我又塑形了另一个面团宝宝。我喜欢管我的肚子叫这个，因为我刚才下楼吃了一小块这个东西。我甚至不知道乔什（Josh）做的到底是什么。它就像某种，吃起来有点像一小方核桃派。太好吃了。我们能给乔什的烘焙主页打个广告吗，拜托？“与乔什和安吉一起烘焙”（Baking with Josh
and Ange, there is a recipe on there for something called a brookie. Okay, you know, I made this the other day. It is a layer of brownie topped with a layer of chocolate chip cookie and their bars. Angela, I ate so many of them that I made myself sick. I made myself sick like I was like a child who couldn't stop eating candy on Halloween. And I felt so ill. And even when I felt sick from eating so many of them, I wanted to eat more of them. That's how good the brookie is, guys. It'll make you sick and you won't care and you'll keep eating it anyway. I don't know what kind of endorsement that is, but I feel like that's a good endorsement. Yeah, well, he has tons of recipes. You guys, my husband is a baker. You can go to bakingwithjoshandange.com for all of his recipes. I don't
and Ange），上面有一个食谱，教大家做一种叫布鲁奇（brookie）的点心。好吧，你知道的，我前几天刚做过。那是底层布朗尼，上面铺着一层巧克力豆曲奇，做成方块状的。安吉拉，我吃得太多了，结果把自己吃吐了。我把自己吃得生病了，就像那种万圣节期间无法克制自己吃糖的小孩一样。我难受极了。甚至当我都因为吃太多而感到恶心时，我还想继续吃。这就是布鲁奇的厉害之处，伙计们。它会让你吃撑到生病，而你根本不在乎，依然会继续吃下去。我不知道这算不算是什么好评，但我觉得这绝对是个好评。对啊，好吧，他有海量的食谱。伙计们，我丈夫可是一位烘焙师。你们可以访问 bakingwithjoshandange.com 去查看他的所有食谱。我才不
even know why I'm in the equation there. It's just that when he bakes, he likes me around. But he is the master. I'm the taste tester and he's the master. That was really sweet, Jenna. Well, if you want to eat so much of something that you make yourself sick, make the brookie. But he also has, guys, not just sweets. He's got like these one sheet meals. And I love to cook things on one sheet because then I only have to clean one thing. Yes, they are really good. We just did his one sheet chicken fajitas. That's my favorite. It's so good. All right. This became a small commercial for bakingwithjoshandange.com, but I stand by it. Well, thanks. That's really sweet. I'll tell him he'll be tickled. All right. Well, let's get back to this episode. Jim
甚至不知道为什么把我扯进去了。只是他烤东西的时候，喜欢我在旁边。但他才是大师。我是试吃员，而他是大师。这真的太贴心了，珍娜。嗯，如果你想吃到腻、吃到生病的话，就去做那个布鲁基饼干。不过，伙计们，他可不仅会做甜点。他还会做那种单烤盘料理。我特别喜欢用单烤盘做饭，因为这样我只需要洗一个盘子。没错，它们真的很棒。我们刚刚做了他的单烤盘鸡肉法士达。那是我的最爱。真的太好吃了。好吧。这段不知不觉成了 bakingwithjoshandange.com 的小广告，但我依然支持它。好吧，谢谢。这真的太甜了。我会告诉他，他一定会乐坏的。好吧，那我们回到这一集吧。吉姆
steals Andy's cell phone. Yeah. And but why does he pass it off to Pam? I don't understand why they trade it twice. What are they, secret spies? Couldn't he have just taken it and gone straight to the bathroom and like chucked it up in the ceiling or something? Yes. This entire prank could have been done by Jim alone. He tried to recruit all these people to do this prank with him that required only one person. He could have pranked Andy on his own, but for Jim, the prank is like the social bonding experience. It's not about like just doing it by himself. What's the fun in that? Exactly. He wants a partner. He wants a buddy. Yes. So he does this weird thing where he knocks over the pens and steals the phone and then gives it to Pam and then Pam
偷了安迪的手机。对。但是他为什么要转交给帕姆？我不理解他们为什么要传手两次。他们是什么秘密间谍吗？他难道不能直接拿了手机，径直走进卫生间，然后把它扔到天花板里或者别的什么地方吗？没错。这个恶作剧完全可以由吉姆一个人完成。他却试图拉拢所有人来和他一起完成这个只需要一个人就能搞定的恶作剧。他明明可以自己一个人捉弄安迪的，但对吉姆来说，恶作剧就像是一种社交联结的体验。这根本不是为了独自完成它。那样有什么好玩的？一点没错。他想要一个搭档。他想要个死党。没错。所以他做了一件很诡异的事，他撞翻了钢笔，偷走了手机，然后交给帕姆，接着帕姆
gives it back to him. And Karen clocks it. Yeah. Karen noticed that. She doesn't know what they're doing, but they're in cahoots. Well, and then, and then you're like his lookout, but you clearly see him. You guys have the most, like you're the most oddball, like duo. I feel like there could have been a spinoff where Jim and Pam are secret spies, but everyone knows. Well, and just to our point earlier, is no one noticing the camera crew following Jim and Pam sneaking and like filming them do this prank? There's a lot of disbelief you have to suspend right here in this moment. Jenna, no one sees it because Pam is so great at distracting them by drinking her water. That's all we see. Pam's just drinking her water and playing with her necklace.
又把它还给了吉姆。而凯伦注意到了。对。凯伦察觉到了。她虽然不知道他们在搞什么鬼，但她知道他们在串通。而且，而且你就像是他的风筝哨（放哨的），但你明显能看到他。你们俩简直是，你们是最古怪的二人组。我觉得完全可以拍个番外篇，讲吉姆和帕姆是秘密间谍，但所有人都心知肚明。而且，呼应我们刚才的观点，难道没有人注意到摄制组一直在跟着吉姆和帕姆，看他们鬼鬼祟祟的还拍他们搞这个恶作剧吗？在这个时候，你真的得忽略掉很多不合理的地方。珍娜，根本没人看到，因为帕姆太会喝水来转移他们的注意力了。我们看到的就只有这些。帕姆就是在喝水，然后玩她的项链。
Nothing to see here. Yeah. What do you mean? What? Well, you have to remember in the last episode, Phyllis kind of spills the beans and says to Karen, I'm so glad you and Jim are together because he was hung up on Pam for so long. So, you know, Karen has got that in her brain. And when she sees the two of them kind of giggling and up to something, she's like, Oh no, what's happening? Yes. Well, meanwhile, Kelly and Oscar are setting up for the party. I think it's very funny that Oscar has to set up his own party. He has chores at his own party. It's amazing. And then Michael, meanwhile, is pouting in the kitchen. He wants to let Jim know that he's not fine. He's not fine. And he's like, he doesn't want to talk about it. But Jim's like, okay. And he's like, okay,
这里没什么好看的。对。你什么意思？什么？好吧，你得记上一集里，菲莉丝不小心说漏了嘴，对凯伦说，我真高兴你和吉姆在一起，因为他一直对帕姆念念不忘。所以，你知道的，凯伦心里一直记着这事呢。当她看到这两人在一旁咯咯笑，而且又在密谋什么的时候，她就会想，哦不，发生什么了？对。嗯，与此同时，凯利和奥斯卡正在布置派对。我觉得很有趣的是，奥斯卡还得亲自布置自己的派对。他得在自己的派对上干杂活。这太绝了。然后与此同时，迈克尔在厨房里生闷气。他想让吉姆知道他可一点都不好。他不好。然后他就，他不想谈这个。但吉姆说，好吧。然后他说，好吧，
I'll talk about it. He's like, okay. Yeah. And he's like, what do you think of Andy? What do you think of Andy? And I love this Angela. Jim is like, well, I mean, he's kind of a yes man. And Michael's like, that's not true. Because when I say I don't like something, he says he doesn't like it too. It's like, Oh, Michael. Oh, Michael, Steve is so brilliant in this episode. I know we talk about how good he is. So like every week. But he had to, I don't even know how to say it. But the way he reacts to Andy is like a whole new version of Michael Scott. Yeah. And he's so brilliant. And the way he doesn't get things and then the audience gets it before him and then he finally gets it. It's just amazing. Well, Angela, he has this talking head that I
我会谈谈的。他说，好吧。对。然后他说，你觉得安迪怎么样？你觉得安迪怎么样？我太喜欢这里了，安吉拉。吉姆就说，嗯，我的意思是，他有点像个唯命是从的人。迈克尔就说，才不是呢。因为当我说我不喜欢某样东西时，他也说他不喜欢。这就像是，哦，迈克尔。哦，迈克尔，史蒂夫这一集里简直太惊艳了。我知道我们几乎每星期都在说他有多棒。但他那种，我甚至不知道该怎么形容。但他对安迪的反应，简直就像是全新版本的迈克尔·斯科特。对。而且他太天才了。那种他搞不懂状况，然后观众比他先懂，接着他终于恍然大悟的样子，简直太绝了。好吧，安吉拉，他有个采访镜头，我
can't even barely watch. Because is it about the raspberry? Yeah, the sherbert thing. It's about the way Steve delivers it is so masterful. But the whole thing just makes me so uncomfortable. Whenever Michael talks about his childhood, I get scared. I just feel like I don't want more details about his loneliness. Yeah. And his like need for attention. And his all of it. His awkward interactions with his mom and stepdad Jeff. I mean, yeah. Yeah. I know. Poor Michael. I know this is totally off topic. But I was impressed that Jim's choice of snack was raw carrots. Yes, Angela. Angela, we had, we had a fan point this out about the carrots. Brianna Kernan wrote in to say, does John really like to snack on carrots? Because he can be seen in multiple
简直没法直视。因为是关于覆盆子的吗？对，那个雪酪的事情。关键在于史蒂夫的演绎方式简直太绝妙了。但整段内容让我浑身不自在。每当迈克尔谈起他的童年，我就觉得害怕。我只是觉得我不需要了解更多关于他孤独的细节。对。还有他对关注的渴望。以及所有这些。他和妈妈以及继父杰夫之间尴尬的互动。我是说，对。对。我懂。可怜的迈克尔。我知道这完全扯远了。但我对吉姆选择的零食是生胡萝卜感到印象深刻。没错，安吉拉。安吉拉，我们，我们有个粉丝指出了胡萝卜这件事。布里安娜·克尔南写信来问，约翰真的很喜欢吃胡萝卜当零食吗？因为在好几集里都能看到他在不同时间段吃胡萝卜。我和约翰拍了很多对手戏。所以，我可以告诉你，如果他在一场戏里有得选的话，他会选择吃健康的食物。他会选择胡萝卜。经常这样。他喜欢胡萝卜，甚至到了剧组最后不得不对他说，约翰，你不能再吃胡萝卜了。这太影响收音了。所以后来他开始吃葡萄。所以你会看到他吃一些葡萄。但有时候剧本会写着我们在吃薯片。他也会吃薯片，但伙计们，他更偏爱健康的零食。他就是这样。我印象深刻，约翰。我真的印象深刻。我，我是说，我通常会要薯片。对。好吧，BJ·诺瓦克和我以前经常说，如果是道具，
episodes snacking on carrots at various times. I did a lot of scenes with John. And so I can tell you that he eats carrots if given the choice for what he gets to eat in a scene, he will pick something healthy. He will pick carrots. A lot. He would pick carrots to the point that they finally had to say, John, you can't with the carrots. It's like really bad for sound. So then he started eating grapes. So you'll see him eat some grapes. But occasionally it would be scripted that we're eating chips. And he would eat the chips, but he preferred a healthy snack, guys. He just did. I am very impressed, John. I'm very impressed. I, I mean, I usually would ask for potato chips. Yeah. Well, BJ Novak and I used to say that if it's a prop,
那就没有卡路里。所以你想吃多少就吃多少。哦，有趣的理论。对，这不是真正的食物。你在假装。这是假装的食物。假装的卡路里。假装的卡路里。你可以，你知道的，我现在会选什么？我会选布鲁基饼干。我会说，请问我能吃一块布鲁基饼干当零食吗？好吧，派对筹备正在进行中，但安吉拉和帕姆在电梯旁进行了短暂的对话。我太喜欢这段了，你知道的，当帕姆问，是因为德怀特吗？然后安吉拉说，不，是约翰·丹佛。你当时就会想，好吧，原来是这样。我撤了。对。不不不不不。但约翰·丹佛难道是她最喜欢的歌手之一吗？这约翰·丹佛是从哪儿冒出来的？对我来说，关于安吉拉·马丁，这真是一个非常有趣的小细节。好吧，安吉拉告诉帕姆她真的很想念德怀特，而且她觉得很难受。对。然后帕姆说，我觉得你应该去跟迈克尔谈谈。而安吉拉却说，帕姆，我可不像你那样穿着挑逗的衣服四处溜达，脑子里冒出什么想法就说什么。对。我太喜欢这句了。当时她正穿着一件套在衬衫外面的毛衣，就像是，什么，安吉拉，这是什么穿搭？你在胡说八道些什么呀？对。不管怎样，安吉拉很感激帕姆能（跟她）谈心，然后给了帕姆一个极其诡异的拥抱。就像她抱了她一下。然后当她意识到自己是在抱你时，她把你猛地推开了。好吧，我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问，安吉拉。卡勒布·费纳和凯莉·坎贝尔都问，那个拥抱是即兴发挥的，还是剧本里写好的？
it doesn't have any calories. So you can eat as much of it as you want. Oh, interesting theory. Yeah, it's not real food. You're pretending. It's pretend food. Pretend calories. Pretend calories. You can, you know, what I would pick now is a brookie. I'd be like, can I snack on a brookie, please? Well, the party set up is underway, but Angela and Pam have a little conversation out by the elevators. And I loved it so much, you know, when Pam's like, is it about Dwight? And Angela's like, no, John Denver. You're like, okay, that's how it's going to be. I'm out. Yeah. No, no, no, no, no, no. But is John Denver like one of her favorite singers? Like, where did John Denver come from? It's just such a funny sort of little bit of detail to me about
你觉得呢，安吉拉？好吧，是即兴的还是剧本里的？我觉得是即兴的。是即兴的。剧本里没有。剧本里没有，那是即兴发挥的。对，对，我觉得你和我用几种不同的方式排练了那场戏。太有趣了。太棒了。真的太棒了。好吧，回到办公区，吉姆一直在给安迪的手机打电话，现在手机正在天花板上响个不停。很多人问，那个手机真的在天花板上放歌吗？按理说，我觉得答案应该是否定的，因为这会破坏你剪辑场景的能力。但是安吉拉，我记得那个手机在天花板上响过啊，难道是我疯了吗？没有，我觉得我也记得。我觉得他们把一个扬声器放到了天花板上，然后让某个人播放那首歌，好让我们做出反应。我脑子里有超级深刻的记忆，就是一整天都听到那个声音在我们的头顶上方。对。对。对。所以，我知道有人会记得。为此我联系了好多人。到底是怎么回事？谁也说不准。但我坚信我个人的记忆，我们确实有，我不知道是不是那部手机，但我们确实一直在听天花板上传来的四声部和声，并对它做出反应。对。我们可不是对着空气演反应。那声音实际上开始变得很烦人了。我确实记得这个。我当时想，真是听够那首歌了。天哪。安吉拉，当我们重温这一集，它第一次响起的时候，我整个人有点，本能地退缩了一下。就像我体内的细胞在说，
Angela Martin. Well, Angela tells Pam that she's really missing Dwight and she feels bad. Yeah. And Pam says, I think you should talk to Michael. And Angela's like, Pam, I'm not like you walking around in your provocative outfit saying whatever thought pops in your head. Yeah. I love that. As she's wearing a sweater over a button down, like, what, what are these outfits, Angela? What are you even talking about? Yes. But anyway, Angela appreciates Pam's, you know, talking with her and gives her such a weird hug. It's like she hugs her. And then when she realizes she's hugging you, she shoves you away. Well, we had a fan question about it, Angela Caleb Fiener and Kylie Campbell both asked, was that hug improvised or was it in the script?
哦不，不是吧，别再来了。别再让记忆重现了。对。因为我记得拍这一集的时候一直在唱它。然后那天晚上我看完重播上床睡觉的时候，我在想，哦，一整天都是这俩人在那儿。我受不了了，我就想，别再这样折磨我了。我们不能跳过我喜欢称之为“灵活菲莉丝”的桥段。对。她太灵活了。她身手敏捷。反应极快。我是说，安迪试图拉开她的抽屉。菲莉丝直接来了一个闭眼猛推。对。推了回去。对。我是说，菲莉丝这反应速度绝了。对，因为安迪到处在找。他根本到处都找不到。好吧，就在安迪找手机的时候，安吉拉像帕姆建议的那样走进了迈克尔的办公室。她说，听着，德怀特那天早上迟到是因为他去送季度税务表格了，而那是她忘记寄出的。而且公平地说，凯文从来没有提醒过她。她只是想让迈克尔知道，如果凯文做好了他的本职工作，她就能把自己的工作做得更好。但是，对，德怀特是在拯救世界。他才不是在搞什么诡异的公司权力争夺呢。他是在帮她的忙。对。我记得在这场戏里，格雷格给我的提示是，你知道的，我走进去的时候，我非常紧张，因为我真的不想让办公室里的人知道我的私事。我不想让他们知道我在和谁约会，尽管我真的很在乎德怀特。我只是讨厌成为办公室八卦的主角，你知道的？对。所以当我走进去的时候，他说，安吉拉，你就跟机关枪似的快速把那些台词倒出来，就像你迫不及待地把一切都倾倒出来一样，你知道吗？对。所以这就是我当时带入的那种能量，就像如果她不马上说出来，她就会失去勇气。所以我当时就说，德怀特去纽约了。他去送了税表。我当时就，你知道的，就随口抛出来。对。然后谢天谢地，迈克尔是个十足的笨蛋。他根本没把这些事串联起来。他就说，哦天哪，德怀特，如果他能为办公室里的任何人做到这一点，还有谁是这样的人呢？你知道的？对。然后我就想，没有别人了。安吉拉高兴坏了。她太高兴了。她能在不暴露恋情的情况下澄清事实。对。迈克尔只把这当作德怀特对公司无限忠诚的象征。对。所以他说，我得把他找回来。
What do you think, Angela? Well, improvised or in the script? I feel like it was improvised. It was improvised. It was not in the script. It was not in the script that was improvised. Yeah, yeah, I feel like you and I played around with that scene a few different ways. It was so fun. That was great. That was great. Well, back in the bullpen, Jim just keeps calling Andy's phone, which is ringing now up in the ceiling. And a lot of people asked, was the phone really in the ceiling playing the song? Now, normally, I feel like the answer would be no, because it would ruin your ability to edit the scene. But Angela, I remember that phone playing up in the ceiling am I going crazy? No, I feel like I remember it too. I feel like they put a speaker up in the
我得把他找回来。对。但就在他朝门口走去的时候，安迪突然蹦到他面前，向他兜售他们这周末要一起去的约会。他劈里啪啦倒出了一大堆活动。然后迈克尔就说，够了，住嘴，你把我逼疯了。安迪就说，哦，如果我的友谊让你感到厌烦的话，我很抱歉。不，抱歉，我的友谊烦到你了。哦，原来是这样。原来是这样。好吧，我们有一个来自阿里·怀特的粉丝提问。她想知道那长串的活动清单是剧本写的，还是埃德·赫尔姆斯即兴发挥的。伙计们，全都是剧本写的。埃德把那些全背下来了。那可不是即兴发挥。这太完美了，因为听上去每一个都是糟糕透顶的夜晚。迈克尔就想，
ceiling and they had someone play that song for us to react to. I have like such a strong memory of hearing it all day long, like over our heads. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So I know one can remember. I reached out to a bunch of people about this. What's the deal? No one is sure. But I'm going with my personal memory that we really did have, I don't know if it was the phone, but we really were listening to that four-part harmony up in the ceiling and reacting to it. Yeah. We weren't reacting to nothing. It was actually getting really annoying. I do remember that. I was like, so sick of that song. Oh my God. Angela, when we were rewatching this episode and it played for the first time, I kind of like, I recoiled a little bit. Like the cells in my body were like,
我才不要做那些事呢。于是现在安迪的手机又开始响了。所以他刚刚才在整个办公区所有人面前被迈克尔公开拒绝。而现在他的手机又响了。然后这个男人彻底崩溃了。他失控了。对。这就是我们跟埃德聊过的那个情节，他必须在墙上砸个洞。安吉拉，我联系了肯特，想确切了解我们为这个特技准备了多少堵墙。结果是几堵？四堵。所以我们本来可以拍四次的。但大家还记得吗，埃德以为他们只需要拍两次。不过现场其实有四次机会。所以这就是为什么当我们和埃德聊天时，我会说，我对这场戏的记忆是我们所有人都必须保持高度专注，打起十二分精神。这样我们就不会毁掉其中一个镜头了。各位，我们当时只有四堵墙。好吧，我发现在会计部的反应镜头里，有一个镜头是奥斯卡站着的，然后画面一切，他又坐着了，然后再一切，就好像是，有点对不上。但我的孩子们可喜欢这个了，他们说，奥斯卡坐着，奥斯卡站着，奥斯卡坐着。而这一切发生的同时，真正让他们觉得好笑的是，那个荷马·辛普森的玩偶被侧着放了，屁股朝天翘着。
oh, no, not again. Not again since memory. Yes. Because I remember shooting this episode and singing it. And then when I went to bed the night I rewatched it, I was like, oh, then the two times all a day long. I couldn't, I was like, don't do this to me again. We cannot skip past what I like to call nimble Phyllis. Yes. She's so nimble. She's agile. She's quick. I mean, Andy tries to open her drawer. Phyllis does the no look slam. Yeah. Push back. Yeah. I mean, that's some quick reflexes Phyllis. Yeah. Because Andy is looking for it everywhere. He cannot find it anywhere. Well, while Andy's looking for his phone, Angela goes into Michael's office like Pam suggested. And she says, listen, the reason Dwight was late that morning was because
哦，荷马倒了。荷马倒了。然后我们不得不回头去找荷马是什么时候立着的，结果他几乎整集都倒在侧边。所以你们懂的。哦，伙计们，这一集的标题就是“荷马倒了”。还有“雪与悲伤”。现在我们来到室外，迈克尔在停车场，他的车里堆满了雪。他要怎么进去啊？他得把雪铲出去。他很赶时间，但他得先把雪挖开。安吉拉，我关于雪有一个超棒的内幕消息。什么？好吧。肯特告诉我，同一家造雪公司用假雪填满了那辆赛百灵（Sebring），但那可不是冰冷的雪。那是一种塑料小雪花，因为假雪有很多不同种类。所以它们是那种塑料小雪花。而在拍摄结束时，他们花了整整第二天一整天的时间才把所有的雪都吸出来。而且那是一辆租赁车。那是他们租的车。他们必须把所有的雪都弄出来。到了这一季结束时，当他们退还这辆车的时候，整整一年过去了，
he was dropping off the quarterly tax forms that she forgot to send. And to be fair, Kevin never reminded her. She just wants Michael to know that if Kevin had done his job, she could have done her job better. But yeah, Dwight was saving the day. He wasn't going for some weird corporate power grab. He was doing this favor for her. Yes. I remember in this scene, Greg gave me the note to, you know, I'm coming in there. I'm very nervous because I really don't want people in the office to know my business. I don't want them to know who I'm dating, even though I really care for Dwight. I just hate the idea of being office gossip, you know? Yeah. So I'm going in there and he said, Angela, just deliver those lines like the top at the top, like you're just
这些雪依然留在那辆车的内部结构里。他说每当他们打开空调，雪就会从出风口里喷出来。他们根本没办法把所有的雪彻底清干净。我想他们退车的时候还得交一笔罚款。我敢肯定他们绝对交了。我敢肯定，因为当别人租下这辆车，打开空调时，这些小小的假塑料雪花就会迎面朝他们飞出来。对。我太喜欢这个内幕了。我太喜欢每次我们试图打开空调时，雪就会从里面喷出来的设定了。好吧，迈克尔现在到了史泰博（Staples）。他要去找德怀特。他要向他道歉。他想让德怀特回来。我太喜欢这场戏了。我是说，德怀特都快哭了。这真的是一个满满的兄弟情（Bromance）时刻。好吧，是的，这就是格雷格对它的称呼。他称之为兄弟情时刻。而且，你知道的，这场戏的背景音乐播放的是《军官与绅士》里的歌。对。还记得《军官与绅士》结尾的那一幕吗，她在工厂里工作，理查·基尔走了进去，把她抱起来亲吻，所有人都在欢呼。那是哪首歌？那是《Love Lift Us Up Where We Belong》。对吧？是的。就是那首。整个那首。好吧，在这一幕中，史泰博超市里播放的正是这首歌的轻音乐版本。这太绝了。伙计们，格雷格发来了一段音频片段，谈到了这个兄弟情。
just quickly spilling it all out, you know? Yeah. So that's why I went in with that energy of just like, like if she didn't say it right away, she was going to lose her nerve. So I was like, Dwight went to New York. He dropped off the tax forms. I was like, you know, just kind of like throw it out. Yes. And then thank God, Michael is such an idiot. He doesn't connect the dots. He's like, oh my God, Dwight, if he would do that for anyone in this office, who else is like that? You know? Yeah. And I'm like, no one. And Angela's so happy. She's so happy. She was able to sort of set the record straight without revealing their relationship. Yes. Michael just takes this as a sign of Dwight's undying loyalty to the company. Yeah. So he's like, I have to go get him back.
《回归》的结尾就像是迈克尔和德怀特之间盛大的兄弟情时刻。我很确信《军官与绅士》这个梗一开始就写在剧本里了。据我回忆，我们一直在为那个时刻做铺垫，看迈克尔穿梭在史泰博的货架之间，试图，你知道的，把它变成一个伟大的浪漫时刻，就像理查·基尔回归寻找黛布拉·温格一样。事实也确实如此。我真的很希望雷恩能把史蒂夫抱起来转一圈。我真希望剧本里有这个。好吧，在这种情况下，雷恩就是黛布拉·温格。我知道，但他比史蒂夫个子大。所以我觉得那会是，比起像剧中那样他脱下史泰博制服，他应该直接把迈克尔抱走才对。不管怎样。好吧，说到他的制服，当德怀特回到邓德米夫林的派对时，他穿着一件《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的运动衫，对吧？对。好吧，你知道这事是怎么回事吗？《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》根本没有出过任何运动衫周边。这不疯狂吗？对。所以我们的服装设计师卡丽·贝内特不得不为德怀特特制了一件《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》周边运动衫。对，他们是专门制作的。市面上根本没有。我发信息问雷恩他是不是还留着那件衣服。哦，快告诉我他说留着。他没留着。而且他超级后悔没有把它顺走。哦，那绝对是一件值得顺走的衣服。我知道。我知道。肯定有人留着。那是仅此一件的绝版。好吧，你知道的，当德怀特回到办公室时，我记得我当时有一场戏是在和奥斯卡说话，而格雷格的要求是，当他走进
I have to go get him back. Yeah. But as he's on his way out the door, Andy like jumps in front of him and pitches him like this weekend date that they're going to go on. He's like blurts out a gazillion things. And Michael is like, just stop, stop, you're driving me crazy. And Andy's like, oh, I'm sorry if my friendship is annoying you. No, sorry, I annoyed you with my friendship. Oh, that's what it is. That's what it is. Well, we had a fan question from Ali White. She wanted to know if that list of activities was scripted or improvised by Ed Helms. Guys, it was all scripted. Ed memorized that. That was not an improvisation. It was perfect because they all sounded like a horrible evening. Michael's like,
房间时，他希望安吉拉·马丁在那个时刻卸下防备。你知道的，所以我毫不掩饰地看着他，眼中充满了爱意和幸福。而且你知道的，我们依然有所保留。我们只是握了握手。对。对。但我们俩之间有太多的情感涌动，而迈克尔却浑然不知。但你确实和他握手了。你用握手的方式欢迎他回归。对。现在，我得问你个问题，安吉拉。你们之前一直没有联系吗？我是说，你们在办公室之外没有见过面吗？你们不去彼此的家里，不通电话吗？我想是的。但我认为他在那份工作里过得很痛苦。而我就是他没能从事自己想做的工作的原因。看到他回到办公室，知道他回到了他想去的地方。而且他为我做的事有着极具层次感的情感。然后我冒险去找迈克尔，所有的这些情绪都在那一刻爆发了。对。这并不是说这是你们一个月来第一次见面。而是他回到了他属于的地方。对。我们俩都为彼此做出了牺牲。对。所以这让我们的关系进入了下一个阶段。我觉得非常微妙，那就是他为我做了那件事。而我走出了舒适圈，为他做了这件事。他心知肚明。我也心知肚明。没错。所以我觉得就是这样。但当然啦，迈克尔对此一无所知。我们用爱意的眼神看着对方，握了握手。然后就结束了。不过，女士们，派对正在火热进行中呢。对。当我们握手和做这一切的时候，每个人都在享受美好的时光。而且，珍娜，我们捕捉到了一个菲莉丝跳舞的绝妙镜头。对。迈克尔对帕姆说，嘿，帕姆，扭一个。我也扭一个。而帕姆说，不。对。对，我才不干呢。但你猜谁特别开心？菲莉丝，在25分18秒的时候。你们都知道菲莉丝曾经是个滑稽杂耍舞者。你们正在看到的是菲莉丝在背景里大跳货真价实的滑稽歌舞。我得告诉你们，那个扭动可不在剧本里。哦，当然不在。所以我不知道我们是从哪儿弄出这招的。但我猜菲莉丝只是即兴发挥，只要有跳舞的机会，菲莉丝绝不缺席。对。不过同时，我只想说，安吉拉，我想指出的是，这个根本不是安吉拉策划的派对却办得好极了。就这些。我很抱歉。她当时也在场。她只是有点放空，但她确实参与了策划。我知道。但也许我们该注意一下这派对办得有多好。哦，天哪。好吧，我把下一幕的标题命名为“呃”。我们又遇到了一个“呃”。这一幕就叫“呃”。休息室里的这幕心碎时刻就被命名为“呃”。好吧，这可是会议室里的心碎时刻。对。所以情况是这样的，伙计们。凯伦和吉姆，他们并排坐在会议室里。他们甚至不说话，也不看对方一眼。他们连看都不看对方一眼。这才是最让人心碎的“呃”的点，当他说他对帕姆余情未了时。他甚至不敢直视她的眼睛。对。她直接起身走人了。她就好像，好吧，去他的。对。因为她问，你对她还有感觉吗？而他说，有。我只想说，吉姆，没错，那个优柔寡断的吉姆消失了。我们迎回了真实的吉姆。吉姆回来了，他在正视自己的真实感受。对，我们很高兴。所以这一集的结尾是德怀特，顺便说一句，他以为这个派对是为他开的，尽管标语上写着“欢迎奥斯卡回归”。有三块标语。有三块写着“欢迎奥斯卡回归”的标语。但不知怎么的，德怀特觉得这个派对是为他办的。他去敲皮纳塔（Pinata），结果直接把它给砸了个粉碎，彻底砸碎了。他把它砸烂了。然后他在办公室里横冲直撞，把挂在办公区天花板上作为装饰的所有皮纳塔全给砸了。在这一集的DVD花絮评论中，他们谈到了这样一个事实：当雷恩开始狂砸
I don't want to do any of those things. So now Andy's phone starts ringing. So he's just been he's just been rejected publicly in front of the whole bullpen by Michael. And now his phone is ringing again. And the man snaps. He loses it. Yes. And this is what we talked about with Ed, where he had to punch a hole in the wall. And Angela, I reached out to Kent to find out exactly how many walls we had prepared for this stunt. And it was how many four. So we could have done four. But remember Ed thought they only had to do it twice. But there were four chances. So that's why when we were talking with Ed, I was like, my memory of this scene was that we all had to have our, you know, game face on. So we didn't ruin one of these takes. We only had four walls, everybody.
皮纳塔时，菲尔·谢伊（道具师）喊道：等一下，等等，等等。这个、这个还有那个，我都有备用道具。你不能砸那个或那个。哦，天哪。所以当你们看到雷恩一路狂奔时，他其实手里有一份“作战地图”，标明了哪些皮纳塔可以砸，哪些不能砸。所以如果你看到他直接跑过一个完好无缺的皮纳塔，那是因为我们没有它的备用道具。所以他必须跑向另一个去砸碎它。这些都是演员在演戏时，普通观众根本不知道他们脑子里要处理的细节。对。安吉拉，我们只有一个话题要聊了，那就是安迪要去参加情绪管理课程，而且他绝对能轻松搞定。原本应该需要10周的课程，他打算5周内就闪电通关。他有一整套周密的计划，
Well, I noticed in the reaction pass in the accounting department, there's one reaction pass where Oscar is standing and then it cuts back and he's like seated and then it cuts back and like so it was like, it didn't quite match up. But my kids loved that they're like, Oscar sitting, Oscar standing, Oscar sitting. And while all of this is happening, the thing they really were tickled by is that the Homer Simpson doll was turned sideways with like his butt in the air. Oh, Homer fell over. Homer fell over. And then we had to go back and look for when Homer was upright and he was on his side pretty much the whole episode. So you guys know. Oh guys, the name of this episode is Homer fell over. And snow and sadness. So now we go outside and Michael is in
通过他惯用的名字重复、个性模仿以及通过点头微笑进行正向强化。他打算在五周内搞定这一切。事实上，他也确实在五周内做到了。埃德，也就是安迪这个角色，将在接下来的五集里缺席。然后他会回归。安吉拉，我们有很多粉丝问了关于这方面的问题。切尔西·莱恩、亚伦·维斯特拉、阿曼达·杰森、布里安娜·克尔南、凯利·韦廷，所有人都问，埃德·赫尔姆斯必须被写走是因为他要去拍别的什么东西吗？没有。没有，我们问过埃德这事。所以，我不知道大家是否还记得之前在《同性恋万圣节》那一集里，我曾跟埃德聊过他是怎么加入这部剧的。还记得他说过他最初只被雇佣了很短的一段时间吗？直到后来，
the parking lot and his car has filled with snow. How's it going to get in it? He's got to like shovel it out. He's rushing, but he has to dig the snow out first. Angela, I have a wonderful tidbit about the snow. What? Okay. Kent told me the same snow company filled that seabring with fake snow, but it wasn't icy snow. It was like the little plastic flakes because there's lots of different kinds of fake snow. So they were these little plastic flakes. And at the end of the shoot day, it took them the entire next day to vacuum all of the snow out. And that was a rental. They rented that car. They had to get all that out of there. And at the end of the season, they kept it for the whole year at the end of the season when they returned it.
他们才决定让他成为剧集的常规演员。好吧，安吉拉，他是怎么解释的呢？他说，等他们决定让他成为常规演员时，他们其实已经把最初那段短期合同里剩下的所有剧集都写完了。而这一集原本的结尾应该是安迪一拳打在墙上，然后被解雇，再也不会回来了。对。在这一集中，我们基本上失去了安迪，然后我们很快又会失去凯伦，对吧？而这本来会为所有斯克兰顿（原话为Stanford，斯潘福德，即斯坦福分公司）的分公司角色的故事线画上句号。但每个人都太爱埃德了，也太爱安迪那种作为德怀特完美死对头的设定了。所以他们想让他回来，并且他们不得不把这事给理顺。这该怎么运作？那种合同会是什么样？我们手里已经有了没有他的剧本。所以他们
This snow was still in like the inner workings of the car. He said whenever they would turn on the AC, snow would blow out of the vent. They never could get all the snow out. And I think they had to pay a fee when they returned it. I'm sure they did. I'm sure they did because someone is going to rent it, turn on the air and these little fake pieces of plastic snow were going to fly out at them. Yes. I loved that tidbit. I loved that every time we tried to turn on the AC, snow would come out of there. Well, Michael has now he's at Staples. He's going to go up to Dwight. He's going to apologize. He wants him to come back. And I love the scene so much. I mean, Dwight is tearing up. It is a very bromance moment. Well, yes, that is what Greg
在五周内把这一切都安排妥当了，然后安迪就回归了。对。而且效果棒极了。与此同时，我记得他们也想让拉什达（ Rashida ）多留一段时间。但她最后接到了《公园与游憩》的工作。对。对，这依然算是在办公室的大家庭里，这真的很有趣。对，因为《公园与游憩》是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯和迈克·舒尔共同创作的。没错。好吧，女士们，在我们在《回归》这一集里说再见之前，你们有没有注意到情绪管理课程那个公司的名字叫什么？没有。我太喜欢了。他们进去的时候门上写着呢。叫什么？“平静远景（Calm Visions）”。哦，你知道吗？我已经不那么生气了。你有产生平静远景吗？我有。我有。搞定。搞定。好吧，
calls it. He calls it the bromance moment. And, you know, playing underneath the scene is the song from an officer and a gentleman. Yes. Remember at the end of Officer and a Gentleman where she's in the factory working and Richard Gere walks in and he scoops her up and they kiss and everyone cheers. It's, what is it? It's love lift us up where we belong. Yes. Right. Yes. Where the E goes. Yes. The whole thing. Well, there is like a muzak version of this playing at Staples during this scene. It's amazing. Guys, Greg sent in an audio clip talking about this bromance. The ending of the return was like the big bromance moment between Michael and Dwight. I'm pretty sure the Officer and a Gentleman was in the
大家这就是《回归》这一集。非常感谢大家的收听。非常感谢我们的嘉宾埃德·赫尔姆斯和格雷格·丹尼尔斯。一如既往地感谢肯特·萨博纳克，也就是“肯特百科”。而且你知道的，珍娜和我，我们联系起人来简直疯狂，哪怕只是发个短信给克里德来帮他恢复记忆，或者我给维特发私信。我是说，我总是无比感激那么多人在珍娜发出请求时能及时回复我们，帮我们把这些播客顺利做出来。好吧，听着，伙计们，我们下周见，这可是我最喜欢的剧集之一：《本杰明·富兰克林》。本杰明·富兰克林。我们到时见。我太喜欢本杰明·富兰克林这一集了。我们下周细聊。好的，大家再见。祝你们过得愉快。再见。
script to begin with. As I recall, we were building towards that moment to see Michael going through the aisles at Staples and trying to, you know, make a big romantic moment out of it, like Richard Gere returning for Deborah Winger. And that is exactly what it is. I really wish Rain had picked Steve up and pulled him around. I wish that had been in the script. Well, Rain is Deborah Winger in this scenario. I know, but he's bigger than Steve. So I think it'd be like that's how they, instead of them disappearing like with him taking his Staples uniform off that he just carries Michael out. Anyway. Well, speaking of his uniform, when Dwight comes back to the party at Dundar Mifflin, he's wearing a Battlestar Galactica
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由欧文、珍娜·费瑟和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费瑟。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演唱的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的 StitcherPremium，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
sweatshirt, right? Yeah. Okay. You know what about this? That Battlestar Galactica did not have any sweatshirt merchandise. Isn't that insane? Yeah. So our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett, had to make up a Battlestar Galactica merch sweatshirt for Dwight to wear. Yes, they made it special. It doesn't exist. I texted Rain and asked him if he still has it. Oh, please tell me he said he did. He doesn't. And he super regrets not snatching it. Oh, that would have been a good one to snatch. I know. I know. Someone has it. It's the one and only. Well, you know, when Dwight comes back in the office, I remember I have this moment where I'm talking to Oscar and Greg was like, when he walks in the
运动衫，对吧？对。好吧。你知道这有什么奇怪的吗？《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》居然没有任何运动衫周边。这不是太疯狂了吗？对。所以我们的服装设计凯瑞·贝内特不得不为德怀特特制了一件《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的周边运动衫。是的，他们是特制的。现实中根本不存在。我发短信问雷恩他是不是还留着。哦，拜托告诉我他说他留着。他没有。而且他非常后悔当时没把它顺走。哦，那确实是一件很值得顺走的东西。我知道。我知道。肯定有人留着。那是绝无仅有的。好吧，你知道的，当德怀特回到办公室时，我记得我有这样一个时刻，当时我正在跟奥斯卡说话，格雷格就说，当他走进
room, I want Angela Martin in the moment to sort of let her guard down. You know, so I'm blatantly looking at him with such like love in my eyes and happiness. And you know, we're still reserved. We just shake hands. Yeah. Yeah. But there's so much emotion like between the two of us and Michael's just oblivious. But then you shake hands with him. You welcome him back with a handshake. Yes. Now, I need to ask you a question, Angela. Have you not been in touch? I mean, you guys aren't seeing one another outside of the office. You don't go to each other's homes, talk on the phone. I think so. But I think he was miserable at his job. And I was the reason he wasn't at the job he wanted to be at. And to see him come back in the office and to know that he's back
房间时，我希望安吉拉·马丁在这个瞬间能稍微卸下防备。你知道的，所以我毫无掩饰地看着他，眼中充满爱意和喜悦。而且你知道，我们还是保持着矜持。我们只是握了握手。对。对。但我们两人之间有那么多的情绪，而迈克尔却浑然不觉。但接着你跟他握手了。你用一个握手欢迎他回来。是的。现在，我得问你一个问题，安吉拉。你们之前一直没有联系吗？我是说，你们在办公室之外没有见过面吗。你们没有去过彼此家里，没有通过电话。我想是的。但我认为他在工作中过得很痛苦。而我就是导致他无法得到他想要的工作的原因。看到他回到办公室，知道他回到了
where he wants to be. And it's so layered what he did for me. And then the risk I took going to Michael, all that emotion is playing out in that moment. Yeah. It's not that it's the first time you guys have seen each other in a month. It's that he's back where he belongs. Yes. And we both made sacrifices for each other. Right. And so it sort of takes our relationship to this next place. I think very subtly of like, he did that for me. And I went out of my comfort zone and did this thing for him. And he knows it. And I know it. Right. So I think it's that. But of course, Michael's oblivious. And we look at each other with love in our eyes and shake hands. And then that's it. The party is well underway, though, lady. Yeah. While we're shaking hands and doing all
他想去的地方。而且他对我的付出包含着太多的层次感。然后我去找迈克尔所冒的风险，所有这些情感都在那一刻爆发了。对。这并不是说这是你们一个月来第一次见面。而是他回到了属于他的地方。是的。而且我们都为彼此做出了牺牲。对。所以这某种程度上把我们的关系推进到了一个新的阶段。非常微妙地体现在：他为我做了那些。而我也走出了舒适区为他做了这件事。他知道。我也知道。对。所以我想就是这样。但当然，迈克尔一无所知。我们用充满爱意的眼神看着对方并握了握手。然后就这样了。不过，女士们，派对已经如火如荼地进行了。是的。在我们握手和做这些
this, everyone's having a good time. And Jenna, we have a fantastic philis dance catch. Yes. Michael says to Pam, Hey, Pam, shake yours. And I'll shake. And she's like, No. Yeah. Yeah, I'm not going to do that. But guess who's so like delighted philis at 25 minutes, 18 seconds. You guys know that philis was a burlesque dancer. And you are seeing a straight up real deal burlesque shimmy in the background by philis. I'll tell you what, that shimmy was not in the script. Oh, of course not. So I don't know where we got that. But I think philis just improvise that any chance to dance philis is in. Yeah. But also, I just want to say, Angela, I want to point out this party's going great that Angela didn't plan. That's all. I'm sorry. She was there. She was just
事情的同时，每个人都玩得很开心。珍娜，我们有一个非常精彩的菲利斯舞蹈抓拍。是的。迈克尔对帕姆说，嘿，帕姆，摇晃你的吧。我会摇晃我的。然后她说，不。对。对，我才不干呢。但你猜谁看起来超级高兴，菲利斯在25分18秒的时候。你们知道菲利斯曾是个滑稽戏舞蹈演员吗？你可以在背景里看到菲利斯实打实的真正的滑稽戏扭动。我跟你说，那个扭动可不在剧本里。哦，当然不在。所以我不知道我们是从哪弄来的。但我认为菲利斯只是即兴发挥，只要有机会跳舞，菲利斯绝不错过。对。不过，我只想说，安吉拉，我想指出这个派对办得真棒，而且不是安吉拉策划的。就这样。我很抱歉。她当时在那。她只是
sort of zoned out, but she was part of the planning. I know. But it's just maybe we should take note of what a great party it is. Oh, my gosh. Well, I titled the next scene, oof. And we have another oof. The scene is just called oof. This was heartbreak in the break room was titled oof. Well, this is heartbreak in the conference room. Yeah. So here's what happens, you guys. Karen and Jim, they're sitting side by side in the conference room. They're not even talking or looking at each other. They're not even looking at each other. That's the even the saddest like oof part is that when he says he's still in the pan. He won't even look her in the eye. Yeah. She just gets up and walks away. She's like, yeah, f this. Yeah.
有点走神，但她确实参与了策划。我知道。但也许我们应该注意一下这是一个多棒的派对。哦，天哪。好吧，我给下一场戏取名为，哎呦。我们又有一个哎呦。这场戏就叫哎呦。这是休息室的心碎时刻，被命名为哎呦。好吧，这是会议室的心碎时刻。对。所以发生了什么呢，伙计们。凯伦和吉姆，他们并肩坐在会议室里。他们甚至没有说话或看着彼此。他们甚至不看对方。这才是甚至最悲伤的哎呦的部分，那就是当他说他还爱着帕姆时。他甚至不愿直视她的眼睛。对。她直接起身走人了。她就像是，去他的吧。对。
Because she says, do you still have feelings for her? And he says, yeah. And I just want to say, Jim, yes, wishy-washy Jim is gone. And we have real Jim back again. Jim is back and he's owning his feelings. Yes, we're happy. So this episode ends with Dwight, who thinks the party is for him, by the way, even though the sign says welcome back Oscar. There's three signs. There's three signs that say welcome back Oscar. But somehow Dwight is like this party's for me. He gets to hit the piñata and he just destroys it, destroys it. He destroys it. Then he goes through the office, just whacking all the piñatas that were decorative piñatas hanging through the bullpen in the DVD commentary for this episode. They talk about the fact that as rain started hitting
因为她问，你对她还有感觉吗？他说，有。我只想说，吉姆，没错，优柔寡断的吉姆已经消失了。我们迎回了真实的吉姆。吉姆回来了，他正视自己的感情。是的，我们很高兴。所以这集以德怀特结束，顺便说一句，他以为这个派对是为他开的，尽管标语上写着欢迎奥斯卡归来。有三条标语。有三条标语上面写着欢迎奥斯卡归来。但不知何故，德怀特觉得这个派对是为他开的。他去打皮纳塔，然后直接把它给毁了，彻底毁了。他把它给毁了。然后他在办公室里走来走去，把挂在大厅里的那些装饰用的皮纳塔全都敲碎了。在本集的DVD评论音轨中，他们谈到了这样一个事实，即当雷恩开始击打
piñatas, Phil Shea was like, hold up, wait, wait, wait. I have duplicates for this one, this one and this one. You cannot hit that one or that one. Oh my gosh. So when you see rain kind of like running through, he had like a little roadmap of which piñata he could hit and he couldn't hit. So if you see him run right past a perfectly good piñata, it's because we didn't have a duplicate for it. So we had to run across to another one and whack it. These are the details people don't know that actors have in their brains when they're doing a scene. Yeah. We only have one more thing to talk about Angela, which is Andy is going to anger management and he's going to crush it. It's supposed to be 10 weeks. He's going to knock it out in five. He has a whole plan
皮纳塔时，菲尔·谢伊就像是，等等，等等，等等。这个、这个还有这个我有复制品。那个和那个你可不能打。哦，天哪。所以当你看到雷恩有点像跑来跑去时，他手里其实有一张小路线图，标明了哪一个皮纳塔能打，哪一个不能打。所以如果你看到他径直跑过一个完好的皮纳塔，那是因为我们没有它的复制品。所以他必须跑到另一个去猛砸。这就是演员在演戏时脑子里才有的那些不为人知的细节。对。我们只有一个问题要谈了，安吉拉，那就是安迪要去上愤怒管理课，而且他会搞定的。本来应该是10周的课程。他要在5周内搞定。他有一整套计划
through his usual name, repetition, personality, mirroring and positive reinforcement through nods and smiles. He's going to he's going to do this in five weeks. And in fact, he does do it in five weeks. Ed, the character of Andy is gone for the next five episodes. And then he returns. And we had a lot of fan questions about this, Angela. Chelsea Lane, Aaron Westra, Amanda Jerson, Brianna Kernan, Kaley waiting, all asked, did Ed Helms have to be written out because he had to film something else? No. No, we had asked Ed about this. So I don't know if you guys remember back in Gay Witch Hunt, when I had talked to Ed about how he came to be on the show. Remember, he said he was originally only hired for a short period of time. And it wasn't until later that
通过他惯常的名字重复、性格模仿、积极肯定以及通过点头和微笑进行正向强化。他要在五周内完成这件事。事实上，他也确实在五周内完成了。埃德，安迪这个角色在接下来的五集里都消失了。然后他回归了。我们关于这个收到了很多粉丝提问，安吉拉。切尔西·莱恩、亚伦·韦斯特拉、阿曼达·杰森、布里安娜·克尔南、凯利·韦丁，都问了，埃德·海尔姆斯是因为要去拍别的什么所以才被写出剧本的吗？没有。没有，我们问过埃德关于这个的事。所以我不知道你们是否还记得在《同性恋女巫猎人》那一集里，当时我和埃德聊过他是怎么加入这部剧的。还记得吗，他说他最初只被雇佣了很短的一段时间。直到后来
they decided to add him as a series regular. Well, I guess Angela, how did he explain it? He said that by the time they decided to make him a series regular, they had actually written all of the episodes to finish out his initial little contract. And this episode was supposed to end with Andy punching the wall and being fired and never coming back again. Yeah. In this episode, we basically lose Andy and then we're soon going to lose Karen, right? And that would have wrapped up all of the Stanford extra character storylines. But everyone just fell in love with Ed and just how Andy was the perfect foil for Dwight. And they wanted him back and they had to sort of figure that out. How does that work? What does that contract look like? We already have these scripts without him. So they
他们才决定让他成为剧集常规演员。好吧，我想问安吉拉，他是怎么解释的？他说，就在他们决定让他成为常规演员的时候，他们其实已经把用来结束他最初那份短期合同的所有剧集都写好了。这一集本来应该以安迪怒砸墙壁被解雇并且再也不回来而告终。对。在本集中，我们基本上失去了安迪，然后我们很快又要失去凯伦了，对吧？那将为所有斯坦福支线角色的故事画上句号。但每个人都爱上了埃德，以及安迪是如何成为德怀特的完美衬托的。他们想让他回归，所以他们不得不找出解决办法。那该怎么操作？那份合同会是什么样的？我们手里已经有了没有他的剧本。所以他们
sorted it all out in five weeks and Andy comes back. Yes. And it was so, so great. And in the meantime, I remember that they were wanting to also keep Rashida around a little bit longer. But she ends up getting a job on Parks and Rec. Yes. Yeah. Which stays sort of in the office family, which is really fun. Yes, because Parks and Recreation was created together by Greg Daniels and Mike Scherr. Yep. Well, lady, before we say goodbye to the return, did you happen to catch what the anger management class, what the name of the company was? No. I loved it so much. It's on the door as they go in. What is it? Calm visions. Oh, you know what? I'm already less angry. Are you having calm visions? I am. I am. Done. Done. Well,
在五周内把一切都理顺了，然后安迪回来了。是的。而且真的太棒了。与此同时，我记得他们还想让拉希达多留一段时间。但她最后接到了《公园与游憩》的工作。是的。对，这依然算是在办公室这个大家庭里，真的很棒。是的，因为《公园与游憩》是格雷格·丹尼尔斯和迈克·舒尔共同创办的。没错。好了，女士们，在我们跟这集回归作告别之前，你们有没有注意到愤怒管理班，那个公司的名字叫什么？没有。我太喜欢了。他们进去的时候门上写着呢。叫什么？平静幻觉。哦，你知道吗？我感觉我已经不那么生气了。你有产生平静幻觉吗？我有。我有。搞定。搞定。好吧，
that was the return, everybody. Thank you so much for listening. A big thank you to Ed Helms for being our guest and Greg Daniels. And as always, Kent Sabornak, Kentapedia. And you know, Jenna and I, we reach out to people like crazy if it's as simple as like a text to creed to jog his memory or I DM'd a vet. Like, I'm just always so appreciative by how many people Jenna respond in a timely manner and get back to us and help us make these podcasts happen. Well, listen, guys, we will see you next week with one of my favorite episodes, Ben Franklin. Ben Franklin. We'll see you then. I love Ben Franklin so much. We'll talk about it next week. All right. Bye, everyone. Have a good one. Bye.
这就是这一集的回归，各位。非常感谢大家的收听。非常感谢我们的嘉宾埃德·海尔姆斯以及格雷格·丹尼尔斯。一如既往地感谢肯·萨博纳克，肯塔百科。你知道的，我和珍娜总是疯狂地联系大家，哪怕只是发条短信给克里德来帮他恢复记忆，或者我给维特发私信。总之，我总是非常感激有这么多人能及时回复珍娜并联系我们，帮助我们让这些播客得以顺利制作。好吧，听着，伙计们，我们下周见，带来我最喜欢的剧集之一，《本·富兰克林》。本·富兰克林。我们到时候见。我太喜欢本·富兰克林了。我们下周再聊。好的。大家拜拜。祝你们过得愉快。拜拜。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由欧文、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西共同制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的 StitcherPremium，请使用优惠码：Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。